Hey there, Will Arnett here from SmartList. It's the podcast where Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes and I interview somebody. Two of us don't know who that person is because one of us has brought on a surprise guest. That's the whole conceit. I wish I could describe it better, but I'm not that smart. So it's SmartList and it's starting now. SmartL Less. Smart. Less.
大家好，我是来自《SmartLess》的威尔·阿奈特。在这个播客里，杰森·贝特曼、肖恩·海耶斯和我将会采访一位嘉宾。我们其中两人不知道嘉宾是谁，因为另外一人请来了一位神秘嘉宾。这就是节目的全部构思。我希望能把它描述得更好，但我没那么聪明。所以这就是《SmartLess》，现在开始。Smart. Less.
Smart. Less. You never did a guest spot over on the Mork and Mindy, huh? No, but I would have. What was your best guest spot when you were a kid? Knight Rider. Yeah, of course. Knight Rider just made my year. I was 15, and so I couldn't drive yet. So this was an opportunity not only to guest on the best show in the world,
Smart. Less. 你以前从来没在《莫克和明迪》里客串过，对吧？没有，但我本来会去的。你小时候客串过最好的节目是什么？《霹雳游侠》。对，当然。《霹雳游侠》简直让我这一年都圆满了。我当时15岁，还不能开车。所以这不仅是一个在世界上最好的节目里客串的机会，
but also drive a Trans Am, owned by The Hoff, and see how they do all the tricks over there. They had like a little guy sitting behind the seat that was like looking through this mesh sort of headpiece in the seat. I loved all the movie magic. I was gonna say, you would've made a good computer.
而且还能开一辆“霍夫”（大卫·哈塞尔霍夫）拥有的火鸟跑车，看看他们是怎么做那些特技的。他们有个小个子坐在座位后面，透过座位里的一种网状头饰往外看。我喜欢所有的电影魔术。我正想说，你本来可以成为一个很好的电脑。
If they already had, you would've been a good, I would've cast you as a computer. I'd still cast you as a computer. Wait because because I know that about you it was on the other day not your episode but Knight Rider and Scotty and I turned it on and they did this like super fancy interior shot of the car and I'm telling you right now it it was disgusting in there. It was like, there was like dust and like wrappers all around it and like all the scratches on it. Like it was not pristine at all.
如果他们已经有了，你本来会是一个很好的……我会把你选为电脑。我还是会把你选为电脑。等等，因为……因为我了解你这一点，那天电视上在放，不是你那一集，是《霹雳游侠》，斯科蒂和我打开看了，他们拍了一个超级精致的车内镜头，我跟你说，里面简直恶心透了。里面全是灰尘，到处都是包装纸，还有各种划痕。一点都不像崭新的。
Yeah, or the onset dresser was not great on the show. 35 years later, you're taking shots at, you know, Transpo and picture cards. Great. Great, we'll have the local on your ass by Monday. Hey guys, I'm so glad that we're here today because we have a guest on our show. And we say this a lot, you know, deserves no introduction, but this is just another example of that. This is a person who has won almost every award it's possible to win in...
是啊，或者说那部剧的现场布置人员不太行。35年后，你还在吐槽运输部门和道具车。太棒了。太棒了，周一当地工会就会来找你麻烦了。嘿伙计们，我很高兴我们今天聚在这里，因为我们节目请到了一位嘉宾。我们经常说，你知道，他不需要介绍，但这又是一个典型的例子。这是一位几乎赢得了所有可能赢得的奖项的人……
Well, you know what? I'll let him tell you about it. Ladies and gentlemen, mr. Ricky Gervais It's nice shot of the awards in the back Guys it's not all of them It's half of them. There's lots of walls. I nearly laughed a couple of times when I was waiting. What did you win the guitar for? I didn't win that. That's just something for the ladies. When they're looking at your awards.
好吧，你知道吗？我让他自己告诉你吧。女士们先生们，瑞奇·热维斯。后面奖杯的镜头拍得不错。伙计们，那不是全部。那只是其中一半。墙有很多面。我刚才等的时候差点笑出声。你赢那个吉他是为了什么？我没赢那个。那是给女士们看的。当她们看着你的奖杯时。
Let me play a little tune for you. Oh my word. what a joy. What a joy this is. Yeah, it's so nice to meet you. I've never met you. I'm a huge, huge, huge fan. Thank you, how's it going, man? Good, man.
让我为你弹一曲。天哪。真是太开心了。这真是太开心了。是啊，见到你真好。我从来没见过你。我是你超级、超级、超级大的粉丝。谢谢，最近怎么样，伙计？很好，伙计。
You guys don't know each other. No. No, you know, there's one time I saw you standing outside of the Beverly Hills Hotel. Creepy. And there was nobody else and I was like, oh my God, that's Ricky, I'm a huge fan, should I say something?
你们俩不认识吗？不。不，你知道，有一次我看到你站在比佛利山庄酒店外面。真吓人。当时周围没人，我就想，天哪，那是瑞奇，我是他的超级粉丝，我该说点什么吗？
And then I fast forwarded in my head if I just go, hey, hey Ricky, I'm Sean. And I didn't know if you know who I was and then you'd be like, hey, and then it would just end. And so I was like, maybe I should skip that. It's kind of how it's going now. It's kind of what's happening. You win.
然后我在脑子里快进了一下，如果我走过去说，嘿，嘿瑞奇，我是肖恩。我不知道你知不知道我是谁，然后你可能会说，嘿，然后就没下文了。所以我当时想，也许我还是别去了。现在的情况也差不多。事情就是这样发生的。你赢了。
Well, you know, one time I was at a Christmas party at Meg Ryan's house, this is decades ago, and Steven Spielberg was in there and I'm talking and I've never met him and he's like, oh my God, and I couldn't believe he knew who I was. We were talking and talking and talking for like two hours. It was awesome. And then I made this huge goodbye.
嗯，你知道，有一次我在梅格·瑞恩家参加圣诞派对，那是几十年前的事了，史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格也在那儿，我正在说话，我从来没见过他，他就像，哦天哪，我简直不敢相信他知道我是谁。我们聊啊聊啊聊了大概两个小时。太棒了。然后我做了一个隆重的告别。
I was like, bye Steven, nice to meet you. I go out to the valet in front of the house and nobody's there, right? And I'm waiting for my car, I'm waiting for my car, and then Steven Spielberg walks up. And it's just us two. And we already had a massive goodbye. So then I was like, hey, how are you?
我说，再见史蒂文，很高兴见到你。我走到房子前面的代客泊车处，那里没人，对吧？我在等我的车，我在等我的车，然后史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格走过来了。就我们俩。我们已经进行过一次隆重的告别了。所以我当时就说，嘿，你好吗？
And it was just awful. It would have been better if he had just said, hi, how are you, I'm Steven, in that moment. Or if he just said, bye, Benjamin. Bye, Benjamin. Ricky, do you remember a few years ago, you were walking across the street in here in LA, and I saw you and Jane walking across and I pulled up my world my window down and I said, Hey, can I get a picture? And you were at first you're like, Oh, fuck,
那真是太糟糕了。如果他当时只是说，嗨，你好吗，我是史蒂文，那会更好。或者如果他只是说，再见，本杰明。再见，本杰明。瑞奇，你还记得几年前吗，你在洛杉矶街头过马路，我看到你和简在过马路，我把车窗摇下来，我说，嘿，能拍张照吗？你起初是说，哦，去你的，
who's how you doing? And you went, Don't give me the fucking wave, it's Will. And you actually got out. We're gonna let the guest talk here in a second, but how many times have you guys been in the car and you like honk at somebody and then you pull up alongside them and you know that person?
谁……你好吗？然后你说，别对我挥手，是威尔。你真的下车了。我们一会儿再让嘉宾说话，但你们有多少次在车里，你对某人按喇叭，然后你开到他们旁边，发现你认识那个人？
Oh yeah. Oh, you mean angrily honk? Yeah, sorry. Americans honk just anything, willy nilly. If an English person honks, it's like in a front it's like people get out what the but in America It's just like you honk for anything. All right. Yeah. Yeah, it's like you've you've you've really devalued the honk No, especially in New York I think you're ready. We should take it back. I think that you're right back So a honk is like it's like the finger or something. What the fuck we should take it back. I think that you're right. Take it right back. So a honk is like the finger or something.
哦，是的。哦，你是说愤怒地按喇叭？是的，抱歉。美国人按喇叭就是随心所欲。如果英国人按喇叭，那就像是一种冒犯，人们会下车问“什么鬼”。但在美国，你什么事都按喇叭。好吧。是啊。是啊，你真的贬低了喇叭的价值。不，特别是在纽约，我想你准备好了。我们应该把它夺回来。我想你是对的。所以按喇叭就像竖中指一样。什么鬼，我们应该把它夺回来。我想你是对的。把它夺回来。所以按喇叭就像竖中指一样。
What the fuck are you doing? We should take them out of time. Hold on, hold on a second. What about time differences? So you're in England. I'm in LA, so I'm drinking coffee. Was that ale I just saw? Ale.
你到底在干什么？我们应该把它……等等，等等。时差问题呢？你在英国。我在洛杉矶，所以我正在喝咖啡。我刚才看到的是艾尔啤酒吗？艾尔啤酒。
Is that what you people call it? Yes, for sooth. It was a mead, sire. Look at that. God, that looks good. It's a beer. As opposed to a lager. Well, it's it's an IPA, an Indian Pale Ale.
你们管那叫这个吗？是的，确实。那是蜂蜜酒，大人。看看那个。天哪，看起来真不错。那是啤酒。相对于拉格啤酒而言。嗯，它是IPA，印度淡色艾尔啤酒。
Yes. And what is that, by the way? That that came in after I stopped. So what is IPA? Oh, am I the only drinker here now? Well, Sean. No, no, no. Sean is a big drinker. Sean's still up from last night.
是的。顺便问一下，那是什么？那是我停止喝酒之后才出现的。所以IPA是什么？哦，我是这里唯一喝酒的人吗？嗯，肖恩。不，不，不。肖恩是个大酒鬼。肖恩昨晚到现在还没睡。
Yeah. What is it? So the Indian Pale Ale, do you know what that is? I can't be more specific. I mean, there's a three word description and I don't know of any other drink that's got three words already to really specify what it is. But wait a second, though. But wait a second. The Indians were not known for making beer when I was last drinking beer. So where did that come from?
是啊。那是什么？所以印度淡色艾尔啤酒，你知道那是什么吗？我无法说得更具体。我的意思是，有一个三个词的描述，我不知道还有什么其他饮料已经用了三个词来真正说明它是什么。但等一下。但等一下。我上次喝啤酒的时候，印度人并不以酿造啤酒而闻名。那它是从哪儿来的？
Sorry, are you saying Indian in the real term, the subcontinent of India in Asia, or what you call? Indians which are Native Americans just thought what you arrogantly called in the end. Yeah I just want to say Ricky just give Jason enough rope. He's about to hang himself Leave some slack on it, but but I'm assuming the Indian of Indian Pale Ale means people from India. Yes? Yes, I think so. I think it was probably something equally racist in British colonial history.
抱歉，你是说真正的印度，亚洲的印度次大陆，还是你们所说的？印第安人，也就是美洲原住民，只是你们傲慢地称之为印度人。是的，我只是想说，瑞奇，给杰森足够的绳子就行。他快要自缢了。留点余地，但我假设印度淡色艾尔啤酒里的“印度”是指印度人。是吗？是的，我想是这样。我想这在英国殖民史上可能同样带有种族主义色彩。
So we said, we're having that. We're having that. This is Indian Pale Ale. It's ours now. It's ours. Honestly, we've gone into rounds beyond my knowledge of what I'm drinking. All I know is, it's 5% alcohol, it's 6pm. That's all I need to know.
所以我们说，我们要喝这个。我们要喝这个。这是印度淡色艾尔啤酒。现在它是我们的了。它是我们的。老实说，我们已经进入了超出我所喝饮料知识范围的领域。我只知道，它是5%的酒精，现在是下午6点。这就是我需要知道的一切。
And do you have, is this a daily thing about this time that you have an Indian Pale Ale? Yes it is. Are you only good for about 20 minutes? Is this an intervention? Yeah, this is intervention, the podcast. I don't know if you knew about that. Come on in, Jane. Jane, come on in.
你每天这个时候都会喝印度淡色艾尔啤酒吗？是的，确实。你是不是只能保持清醒20分钟？这是干预治疗吗？是的，这是干预治疗，这个播客。我不知道你知不知道。进来吧，简。简，进来吧。
I'm gonna jack up in a minute. Is that all right? Oh, that's fine. It's just drinking. We don't mind. Exactly, yeah. So did you just, now you're rewarding yourself because you've just probably just popped out of the gym.
我一会儿要打针了。没问题吧？哦，没关系。只是喝酒。我们不介意。没错，是的。所以你刚才，现在你在奖励自己，因为你可能刚从健身房出来。
You're probably in and out of it. I have. Yeah, have you? Would you, oh, of course you have. Look at that. Showing us his guns. And that's all natural. People say to me, hey, you're probably in and out of it. Yeah, have you? Would you, oh, of course you have, look at that. Showing us his guns. And that's all natural. People say to me, hey, you on the juice.
你可能进进出出的。我有。是吗？你有吗？你会，哦，当然你有。看看那个。向我们展示他的肌肉。而且那是纯天然的。人们对我说，嘿，你是不是用了药。
I go, fuck you, fuck you! Jesus, but that's why they think you're rage is outrageous. You know, you do have a build, Ricky, you always have. Was there a time in your life when you were a gym rat and you just loved to just blast buys and back? No. Blast. Listen.
我说，去你的，去你的！天哪，这就是为什么他们觉得你的愤怒很离谱。你知道，你确实有那种体格，瑞奇，你一直都有。你生命中有没有一段时间你是健身狂，只喜欢练肱二头肌和背部？没有。练。听着。
You must have, because you're not born with pipes like that, are you? No. It's a shame this is only audio, because they can't see me. They can imagine. I'm posing at the moment and I've got terrible my fake tan is dripping off me I do it with a guitar and an IPA Exactly. Yeah, I do work out every day. I try to It's getting harder and harder
你一定练过，因为你天生没有那样的肌肉，对吧？没有。真可惜这只是音频，因为他们看不到我。他们可以想象。我此刻正在摆姿势，而且我很难看，我的假晒黑正在往下滴，我拿着吉他和IPA。没错。是的，我每天都锻炼。我尽量。这越来越难了。
But and I probably shouldn't be because everything is absolutely fucked on me now. I've got two sprained ankles, which is terrible. I still run on terrible knees. I can't bend without them cricking. I've got a bad back. My shoulders are fucked. I've got tennis elbow. Yeah, I'm absolutely, but I refuse to stop doing anything.
但是，我可能不应该这样，因为我现在浑身都彻底废了。我有两次脚踝扭伤，这太糟糕了。我仍然用糟糕的膝盖跑步。我弯腰时它们就会咔咔作响。我背不好。我的肩膀废了。我有网球肘。是的，我彻底废了，但我拒绝停止做任何事情。
Mostly from street fighting, is that right? Because I heard it's mostly. I'm like, yeah, yeah. Hand to hand. But I refuse to stop doing anything mostly from street fighting is that right? Yeah, I'm punch drunk But how old are you 59? Yeah, I'm about to be 52 and everything hurts Oh, you're older than me. You know Dare you this hair is real. Oh, yeah, I've had no work. I don't have two body waxes a day. Wait a second. Fucking Botox, you twat. I'm on swim team. I can't have any hair on my body.
主要是因为街头斗殴，对吧？因为我听说主要是。我心想，是啊，是啊。肉搏战。但我拒绝停止做任何事情，主要是因为街头斗殴，对吧？是的，我被打得晕头转向。但你多大了？59岁？是的，我快52岁了，浑身都疼。哦，你比我大。你知道，敢说我。这头发是真的。哦，是的，我没做过任何手术。我一天没做两次身体脱毛。等一下。去你的肉毒杆菌，你这个混蛋。我是游泳队的。我身上不能有任何毛发。
You're only, he's only 52. Is he telling the truth, Will? No, I won't be 52 till January. Christ. He won't turn to the side because then you'll see the scotch tape and all the rubber bands and stuff. But he, from the front, he looks amazing. From the front. Ricky, do you have a place in LA or do you only live in England? I've got a place in New York.
你才52岁，他在说实话吗，威尔？不，我到一月才52岁。天哪。他不会侧身，因为那样你就会看到透明胶带和所有的橡皮筋之类的东西。但他从正面看，看起来棒极了。从正面看。瑞奇，你在洛杉矶有住处吗，还是你只住在英国？我在纽约有住处。
I've lived for a while, actually. But especially this year, I've spent most of my time in Leafy Hampstead. Will's been here. It's beautiful. It's a great spot and you live next to the vicar. I do, yeah. Who is that? It's just a vicar. He said the vicar, but it's a vicar. There's thousands that I live next to one of them. What's a vicar? A vicar? You don't know what a vicar is? Uh oh. Allow Ricky to relieve you of your ignorance. Go ahead, Ricky. A vicar? You must...
我住过一段时间，实际上。但特别是今年，我大部分时间都待在绿树成荫的汉普斯特德。威尔去过那里。那很美。那是个好地方，而且你住在牧师隔壁。我确实住在那里。那是谁？只是个牧师。他说“那个牧师”，但它就是个牧师。有成千上万个，我住在其中一个隔壁。什么是牧师？牧师？你不知道什么是牧师？哦哦。让瑞奇来缓解你的无知吧。说吧，瑞奇。牧师？你一定……
It's a deep list. Like a preacher. Like a preacher. Like a local priest. Yeah. Yeah. So you live next to a priest? A vicar, yeah. It's true. You live next to a priest's house? Listen, this podcast is... I mean, it's like I'm teaching you that English I have to explain it I mean we spent three minutes on what's Indian pale ale
这是一个很深的列表。就像传教士。就像传教士。就像当地的牧师。是的。是的。所以你住在牧师隔壁？牧师，是的。是真的。你住在牧师家隔壁？听着，这个播客是……我的意思是，就像我在教你英语，我得解释它。我的意思是，我们在“什么是印度淡色艾尔啤酒”上花了三分钟。
it's not that important what's a vicar? Fucking hell. Well you listen you've spent time with Bateman before for Christ's sake you know what you're getting into. I have, I couldn't believe my luck. I was a huge fan of Teen Wolf. Sure, two. Two? Oh, I haven't seen two. No. You're not, ah. Can I, so can I tell you, so the first time, Ricky,
这不重要，什么是牧师？去你的。好吧，听着，你以前和贝特曼待过，看在上帝的份上，你知道你会遇到什么。我待过，我简直不敢相信我的运气。我是《狼少年》的超级粉丝。当然，第二部。第二部？哦，我没看过第二部。不。你不是，啊。我可以，我可以告诉你吗，所以第一次，瑞奇，
that I became aware of you was from watching The Office and Janine Graffalo had video tapes at the time of The Office and she brought them back and she gave them to Amy and me and we watched them. We were about to start Arrested Development and Jason and I started watching both obsessively and we were just absolutely obsessed with The Office and we just thought we'd never seen anything like it. It was just brilliant and I remember about you were coming that you would come to LA for maybe the Golden Globes or something and and We met briefly and we exchanged numbers and you were gonna come to the set of Arrested Development
我注意到你是因为看《办公室》，当时珍妮·加罗法洛有《办公室》的录像带，她带回来给了艾米和我，我们看了。我们当时正要开始拍《发展受阻》，杰森和我开始痴迷地看这两部剧，我们完全被《办公室》迷住了，我们觉得从来没见过这样的东西。它太精彩了，我记得你当时要来洛杉矶，可能是为了金球奖之类的，我们简短地见了面，交换了号码，你本来要来《发展受阻》的片场。
You remember and I remember saying to the the set PA I said I can't get a drive-on at the lot and she said yeah Give me the name and I said Ricky Gervais And you weren't yet a household name in this country. I'm still not. And she said, well, and she said, what is it? I said, Ricky Gervais. And she said, can you spell it for me? And I actually stopped her and I said, I want you to remember this moment of you not knowing
你记得吗，我记得我对片场制片助理说，我说我没法在片场拿到通行证，她说，好的，给我名字，我说瑞奇·热维斯。你当时在这个国家还不是家喻户晓的名字。我现在还不是。她说，嗯，她说，那是什么？我说瑞奇·热维斯。她说，你能为我拼写一下吗？我真的拦住她，我说，我希望你记住这一刻，你不知道
this name because you're going to be really embarrassed when you look back at it. And she was like okay whatever and and you came and that was our first experience and we were just Jason do you remember how blown away we were back we couldn't I couldn't get enough of that show and I still it's uncomfortable for me to even talk to Ricky I'm a little starstruck he the it was oh I ended up getting enough of it I ended up getting enough of it you it that was at the very beginning of the show. That and Jeffrey Tambor shaped, at least for me,
这个名字，因为当你回首往事时，你会感到非常尴尬。她说，好吧，随便吧。你来了，那是我们的第一次经历，我们当时只是……杰森，你记得我们当时有多震撼吗？我无法满足于那部剧，我仍然……对我来说，甚至和瑞奇说话都感到不自在，我有点被明星光环震住了。我最终看够了，我最终看够了。那是剧集刚开始的时候。那和杰弗里·坦伯塑造了，至少对我来说，
the whole comedic tone of Arrested Development. 100%. I kind of knew that there was that kind of funny, but I'd never seen it executed so consistently. And that was just sort of my North Star, what I was trying to, you know, point towards. It was a weird way to say this, but it was liberating to watch you in that show it really was it opened up a whole other for me anyway it felt like it opened up a whole other
《发展受阻》的整个喜剧基调。100%。我当时就知道那种幽默，但我从来没见过执行得如此一致。那就像我的北极星，我试图，你知道，指向的方向。这是一个奇怪的说法，但看你在那部剧里的表现是一种解脱，真的，它打开了另一个……对我来说，它感觉像是打开了另一个
way like okay this this is a possibility to go if he's not acting well we can all get away with it then I can do yeah I mean he's just mumbling and not looking yeah he makes me look like a genius. I mean... The comedy of discomfort and awkward pauses and loss of dignity with just sort of a look or a moment as opposed to jokes or anything like that. And that the length of those episodes allowed for that kind of editorial pace too is something that we sort of tried for.
方式，就像，好吧，这是一种可能性，如果他演得不好，那我们都可以蒙混过关，那我可以做……是的，我的意思是，他只是在嘟囔，没有看镜头，是的，他让我看起来像个天才。我的意思是……不适感和尴尬停顿的喜剧，以及尊严的丧失，只是一种眼神或一个瞬间，而不是笑话之类的东西。而且那些剧集的长度也允许那种编辑节奏，这也是我们试图尝试的。
I don't think we could with with our format but... Well I think it was lucky the format allowed me to do that with a fake documentary because I was emulating something. I was trying to emulate a very ordinary man who wanted to be famous so it was sort of it was easy to not be a trained actor doing that. Do you know what I mean? Yeah of course but what was the genesis? We've never really... I'm sure you've had to explain it before. It was an impression I used to do of like bosses and stuff. I worked in an office for
我不认为我们能用我们的格式做到，但是……嗯，我认为很幸运，这种格式允许我用伪纪录片的形式做到这一点，因为我在模仿某种东西。我试图模仿一个想出名的非常普通的人，所以做那个并不需要受过训练的演员。你知道我的意思吗？是的，当然，但起源是什么？我们从来没有真正……我相信你以前一定解释过。那是我过去常做的关于老板之类的模仿。我在办公室工作了
like 10 years. So it was like a Frankenstein of people I'd met growing up. And you suddenly... And I was always the idiot. I was always trying to make people laugh. And you know, I was that guy. I was sort of that guy without ambition or rather without nerve. I think I'd lost my nerve, I'd just been a failed musician after like five years of trying. I got a normal job and then I worked my way up to sort of middle management in an office like that. In fact the little pre-pilot that we shot, I went back to the office I used to work in and I used mates as extras. And I just ad-libbed around this character showing off to the camera.
大概10年。所以它就像是我成长过程中遇到的人的科学怪人。你突然……我一直是个白痴。我总是试图逗人笑。你知道，我就是那个人。我就是那种没有野心，或者说没有胆量的人。我想我失去了胆量，在尝试了五年之后，我只是一个失败的音乐家。我找了一份正常的工作，然后我一路升到了像那样的办公室里的中层管理人员。事实上，我们拍摄的小型预告片，我回到了我曾经工作的办公室，我用了朋友作为临时演员。我只是围绕这个角色即兴发挥，在镜头前炫耀。
And the seed of that was we had 10 years of these quaint docu-soaps in the 90s on British TV. The new big thing was docu-soaps. We had one called Airport, we had one called Hotel, we had one called Liner, was the set. And it was just normal people filmed, and they'd become sort of stars for 10 minutes. And of course nowadays, they become stars forever
而这一切的种子是，我们在90年代的英国电视上有10年的这种古雅的纪录片肥皂剧。新的大事件是纪录片肥皂剧。我们有一个叫《机场》，有一个叫《酒店》，有一个叫《邮轮》，就是场景。只是拍摄普通人，他们会成为10分钟的明星。当然，现在，他们永远成为明星
and make millions. But then that was their 15 minutes of fame and you wheel them out. So it was ordinary people wanting to be famous. And was it the same type of format? Would they address camera? Would there be testimonials and things like that? Yeah, there was usually a narration as well.
并赚取数百万。但那时那是他们15分钟的名声，你把他们推出来。所以是普通人想要出名。格式是一样的吗？他们会对着镜头说话吗？会有感言之类的东西吗？是的，通常也有旁白。
But we didn't do that. But there was often, it was things like the cement for the swimming pool was late and they have to open it around. It was stuff like that. Right. Was it sort of a Michael Aptid? Was it inspired by the up series at all do you think well that was that's the The greatest that's incredible. I mean that's still going and yeah Yeah, but that's that really is beautiful social commentary sure these got watered down
但我们没那样做。但经常会有，比如游泳池的水泥迟到了，他们不得不绕着它开。就是那种东西。对。那是某种迈克尔·艾普特式的吗？你认为它受到《人生七年》系列的启发了吗？那是……那是……最伟大的，那太不可思议了。我的意思是，那还在继续，是的，是的，但那确实是美丽的社会评论。当然，这些被淡化了。
You know and then people would be doing them because they think, well, I can be famous. Everyone says, I'm a laugh, I'll go on there. And it's like, there was suddenly too much, you know? So then it was people trying to be famous. And so that's what I picked up on with Brent, that he was a bit sad, he was forgotten, and he thought, now's my chance. And if it wasn't a fake documentary, it wouldn't work.
你知道，然后人们会做这些，因为他们认为，好吧，我可以出名。每个人都说，我很有趣，我会去那儿。就像，突然之间太多了，你知道吗？所以那是人们试图出名。这就是我从布伦特身上捕捉到的，他有点悲伤，他被遗忘了，他想，现在是我的机会了。如果不是伪纪录片，它就不会奏效。
Because once you know why David Brent is acting like that, it's so tangible. It's so great that he just wants to be loved and famous. And it's heartbreaking in a hilarious way, yeah. I think that one of the things that I, certainly I personally really connect with with what you do is, is it that desperation. So many of your characters have this sort of misplaced,
因为一旦你知道大卫·布伦特为什么要那样做，它就太具体了。他只是想被爱和出名，这太棒了。这是一种滑稽的令人心碎，是的。我认为我个人与你所做的事情真正产生共鸣的一点是，那种绝望。你的许多角色都有这种错位的，
or they just are so desperate for whatever it is. It's so funny. It's so funny and sad at the same time. I think the funniest characters, and obviously in real life, the documentary aspect of it, we like real life is the most dramatic and the funniest. Comedy and fiction can only try to emulate all those things in real life. But someone trying to be funny and is successful isn't as funny as someone who doesn't want to be
或者他们只是对某种东西非常绝望。这太搞笑了。这既搞笑又悲伤。我认为最有趣的角色，显然在现实生活中，纪录片的方面，我们喜欢现实生活是最戏剧化和最有趣的。喜剧和小说只能试图模仿现实生活中的所有那些东西。但一个试图变得有趣并成功的人，不如一个不想变得
funny and wants to be taken seriously. So my favorite characters were those people that demanded being taken seriously. So it undermines favorite characters were those people that demanded being taken seriously. So it undermines everything. Someone being pretentious and then slipping on a banana skin is funnier than a clown slipping on a banana skin because we know the clown doesn't care. He wants to slip on it. So I think when someone wants to be taken seriously or says things like, I am a comedian, that's funny.
有趣并想被认真对待的人有趣。所以我最喜欢的角色是那些要求被认真对待的人。所以它破坏了……最喜欢的角色是那些要求被认真对待的人。所以它破坏了一切。一个自命不凡的人然后踩到香蕉皮比一个小丑踩到香蕉皮更有趣，因为我们知道小丑不在乎。他想踩到它。所以我认为当有人想被认真对待或说出诸如“我是一个喜剧演员”之类的话时，那很有趣。
I remember getting a letter soon after the office, right? By someone saying, writing to get a part. And the letter started, dear Mr. Gervais, I am a brilliant actor. And I thought it was... Signed Sean. He went... Oh, so you got it.
我记得在《办公室》之后不久收到了一封信，对吧？有人写信来争取一个角色。信的开头是，亲爱的热维斯先生，我是一个出色的演员。我想那是……肖恩签名的。他去……哦，所以你收到了。
You got it. Cause I didn't, I still haven't heard, so I don't know if you got it. You got it. Because I still haven't heard, so I don't know if you got it. Yeah, desperation's funny, anger's funny. People with no sense of humor is funny. People with no sense of humor is funny. The best. One of the things I think is so admirable about you,
你收到了。因为我没有，我还没听说，所以我不知道你是否收到了。你收到了。因为我还没听说，所以我不知道你是否收到了。是的，绝望很有趣，愤怒很有趣。没有幽默感的人很有趣。没有幽默感的人很有趣。最棒的。我认为你身上最令人钦佩的事情之一，
and there's no question here, so don't feel the need to respond, because I know your humility will keep you from doing that, but all the vulnerability that you put into, all the vulnerability that you put into David Brent and many other characters that you play is really the root of the comedy. The man is so broken and a mess inside
这里没有问题，所以不要觉得有必要回应，因为我知道你的谦逊会阻止你这样做，但你投入到大卫·布伦特和你扮演的许多其他角色中的所有脆弱性，确实是喜剧的根源。这个人内心如此破碎和混乱，
that that is what I find so heartbreakingly hilarious about it. Yet on your stand-up It is almost the polar opposite of that in that there's so much confidence and Judgment is sort of this the character that you play and you can still get equal laughs with that So the fact that you're able to make people you know, that's very interesting because I Don't think you need Stand up slightly different.
这就是我发现它令人心碎地搞笑的地方。然而在你的单口喜剧中，它几乎与此完全相反，因为有太多的自信和判断力，某种程度上是你扮演的角色，你仍然可以从中获得同样的笑声。所以你能够让人们，你知道，这非常有趣，因为我不认为你需要……单口喜剧略有不同。
Stand up is slightly different to fiction in the sense that when you do a sitcom or a film or whatever, you do your best and you try and make the plot work and the characters work and the art and you do all that and then you put it out there and there's nothing you can do about it. With stand up, you do it every night and the audience, it's more like evolution by natural selection because they choose the bits for you. but you do it every night and the audience, it's more like evolution by natural selection because they choose the bits for you. It's more like a science
单口喜剧在某种意义上与小说略有不同，当你制作情景喜剧或电影或任何东西时，你尽力而为，你试图让情节和角色发挥作用，艺术，你做所有这些，然后你把它发布出去，你对此无能为力。在单口喜剧中，你每晚都做，观众，它更像是自然选择的进化，因为他们为你选择了片段。但你每晚都做，观众，它更像是自然选择的进化，因为他们为你选择了片段。它更像是一门科学，
because it either works or it doesn't. And by the end, you've got a perfect thing that works every night to everyone around the world because it's tried and tested. It's, you know, they've chosen it for you. So that's slightly different. So what you don't want with standup is an audience to feel sorry for you
因为它要么奏效，要么不奏效。到最后，你就有了一个每晚对世界各地每个人都奏效的完美东西，因为它经过了尝试和测试。它，你知道，他们为你选择了它。所以这略有不同。所以你在单口喜剧中不想要的是观众为你感到难过，
because you haven't got time. You don't want that. No, you don't want that. Noup is an audience to feel sorry for you because you haven't got time. You don't want that. No, you don't want that. No, because it's the purest, like the purest, sorry, because it's the purest. Because jokes are more of an intellectual pursuit. You don't really need a context for jokes. Again, because they work or they don't. A joke can sort of work on the page. You can read a joke and it still works. You don't need someone telling it. Obviously you add to that. I think my favorite stand-ups do add to that. They've got a context, they build character.
因为你没时间。你不想要那个。不，你不想要那个。不，因为它是最纯粹的，就像最纯粹的，抱歉，因为它是最纯粹的。因为笑话更像是一种智力追求。你真的不需要笑话的背景。同样，因为它们奏效或不奏效。一个笑话可以在纸面上奏效。你可以读一个笑话，它仍然奏效。你不需要有人讲它。显然你增加了这一点。我认为我最喜欢的单口喜剧演员确实增加了这一点。他们有背景，他们塑造角色。
They've got props. Yeah. Props in a bag. Sure, those are your favorite stand-ups. You love a prop comic, be honest. You are being humble here. What I'm trying to say is that the comedic flavor, right, your comedy comes from vulnerability, let's say, in David Brent,
他们有道具。是的。包里的道具。当然，那是你最喜欢的单口喜剧演员。你喜欢道具喜剧演员，说实话。你在这里很谦虚。我想说的是，喜剧风味，对吧，你的喜剧来自脆弱性，比如说，在大卫·布伦特身上，
but with the stand-up, it comes from sort of this feigned brash arrogance, and that you're able to do both so well, I find just incredible. Well, that's just because it's another character and you commit to it, and that evolves as well. But you can't just write a bunch of jokes and anybody can say them and they're going to get the same laugh. No, but you can, because, like, um, by the time humanity came around,
但在单口喜剧中，它来自某种假装的傲慢，你能够把两者都做得这么好，我觉得简直不可思议。嗯，那只是因为它是另一个角色，你致力于它，而且它也在进化。但你不能只是写一堆笑话，任何人都可以说它们，它们会得到同样的笑声。不，但你可以，因为，比如，在《人性》出现的时候，
I'd sort of hit that sweet spot where the audience had known me for 15 years. So they knew what I was doing. They knew the irony. They understood the nuance without me having to explain it, so I could come out and hit the ground running. The important thing is this. behind the scenes, right, I think with particularly stand-up, is traditionally it's a low status thing. It's like we're a court jester.
我有点达到了那个甜蜜点，观众已经认识我15年了。所以他们知道我在做什么。他们知道讽刺。他们理解细微差别，而不需要我解释，所以我可以出来并立即开始。重要的是这一点。在幕后，对吧，我认为特别是单口喜剧，传统上它是一种低地位的事情。就像我们是宫廷小丑。
We go out there with the other peasants and we tease the king, okay? And everyone knows what comedians earn these days, so I can't really go out there and pretend to be struggling, right? I think that would be nauseating and dishonest. I would like to see you try though. Yeah. So I keep my low status in two ways. One, I invite them behind the curtain.
我们和农民一起出去，我们戏弄国王，好吗？每个人都知道喜剧演员现在赚多少钱，所以我不能真的出去假装在挣扎，对吧？我认为那会令人作呕和不诚实。但我确实想看你尝试一下。是的。所以我用两种方式保持我的低地位。第一，我邀请他们到幕后。
I say, what, you think it's plain sailing, do you, being rich? Well, look what happened to me when I met so-and-so, or the first time I took a private jet, they thought I was the cook. So I do all that, right? And the other way I do it is I talk about things where I'm worse off than them. I talk about being fat and old and in pain and going bald. And do you know what I mean?
我说，什么，你以为这很顺利吗，很有钱？好吧，看看我遇到某某人时发生了什么，或者我第一次坐私人飞机时，他们以为我是厨师。所以我做所有这些，对吧？另一种方式是我谈论我比他们过得更糟的事情。我谈论变胖、变老、痛苦和秃顶。你知道我的意思吗？
And being hated by the press. I don't know what you mean. I don't know what you mean. But let me... Do you think, I mean, Ricky, you started as a stand-up. You were doing stand-up before, right? You'd been doing stand-up off and on, yeah, for years. No, I started before the office, but I only started in about 1999, I'd say, was my first try.
还有被媒体憎恨。我不知道你的意思。我不知道你的意思。但让我……你认为，我的意思是，瑞奇，你开始是做单口喜剧的。你以前在做单口喜剧，对吧？你以前断断续续地做单口喜剧，是的，做了几年。不，我在《办公室》之前就开始了，但我大概只在1999年左右开始，我想，是我的第一次尝试。
And then you started doing that in 1999, then the office hits, and then over the last 10 years or 15 years, as you've grown and done more and more stand-up, you kind of, you build that currency right with your audience Like that that's the thing you build the momentum of that sort of relationship that you yeah I have to go out there and I want to be the one that says the wrong thing whatever Whatever the current regime is I have to say the wrong thing I have to go against the grain which is why it was hard for the last sort of few years. You know, I didn't realize half the people would agree with those things on face value. So irony was put in danger recently.
然后你在1999年开始做那个，然后《办公室》火了，然后在过去10年或15年里，随着你的成长和做越来越多的单口喜剧，你有点，你建立了那种货币，对吧，与你的观众。就像那是你建立那种关系动力的东西，你……是的，我必须出去，我想成为那个说错话的人，无论当前的政权是什么，我必须说错话。我必须逆流而上，这就是为什么过去几年很难。你知道，我没想到一半的人会从表面上同意那些事情。所以讽刺最近处于危险之中。
Yeah, I remember I remember going to that small little theater, you were working stuff out. Remember, like a couple years ago, I came up there. Yeah. And you're working out jokes in the audience. And I remember you. First of all, the relationship was they knew you, they came because they were huge fans. You had a limited number of seats. It was basically free, but you were working stuff out and the relationship was, hey, I'm trying stuff and some stuff was, you know, over the line for them or whatever, but you were figuring out. Well, that's the thing, you know, You do have to find the funny, but you have to go for it, and you have to be able to play. And that's the problem, again, with today as well,
是的，我记得我记得去那个小剧院，你在排练东西。记得吗，几年前，我去了那里。是的。你在观众面前排练笑话。我记得你。首先，关系是他们认识你，他们来是因为他们是超级粉丝。你的座位有限。它基本上是免费的，但你在排练东西，关系是，嘿，我在尝试东西，有些东西，你知道，对他们来说越界了，或者其他什么，但你在弄清楚。嗯，这就是事情，你知道，你确实必须找到有趣的地方，但你必须去尝试，你必须能够玩。这就是问题所在，再次，今天也是，
because I've done shows that I'm trying stuff out, and it's been reviewed. And I'm gonna go, well, that's mad. You can't do that. You can't do someone who's just started a painting, going, it's rubbish. I haven't done it yet, I've just done the back. You know, it's crazy. So't done it yet I've just done the back you know it's it's crazy
因为我做过我正在尝试东西的节目，它被评论了。我会说，好吧，那太疯狂了。你不能那样做。你不能对一个刚开始画画的人说，那是垃圾。我还没做完，我只是做了背景。你知道，这太疯狂了。所以你必须对抗那个，而且，嗯，我尽量把政治，精致的政治排除在喜剧之外，因为我认为如果你依赖观众同意你并获得掌声，它在喜剧上就失去了一些东西。我希望我的笑话被喜欢，我不在乎它们是右翼还是左翼还是什么，对吧，因为笑话要么奏效，要么不奏效。而且它实际上不应该重要。无论如何，现在左翼和右翼都是无意义的。这是一个无意义的术语。但我认为重要的是你进化，但不是因为那些原因。你不会因为可能被误解而进化。你不会因为可能被评论家欺负而进化。你不会因为想让每个人都喜欢它而进化。那让你一事无成。
so you you have to fight against that and um I try and keep politics, exquisite politics out of comedy because I think if you're relying on the audience agreeing with you and getting around applause it loses something comedically I want my jokes to be liked I don't care whether they're right wing or left wing or whatever right because the joke either works or it doesn't. And it actually shouldn't matter. It's meaningless anyway nowadays, left and right wing. It's a meaningless term. But I think it's important that you evolve, but not for those reasons. You don't evolve because it might be taken the wrong way. You don't evolve because you might be bullied by a reviewer. You don't evolve because you want everyone to like it. That gets you nowhere.
那是什么时候发生在你身上的？因为那是一种你必须达到的无畏。你不能，我相信当你年轻得多的时候，你的一部分没有那个，对吧？我现在可能有了更多的恐惧，但你必须对抗它。你必须知道艺术是勇敢的，它是勇敢的，并把它发布出去，因为你现在有更多的东西要失去，对吧？嗯，这只是让我生气，如果……这让我生气，
When did that happen for you? Because that's a certain fearlessness that I think you have to achieve. You can't, I'm sure there was part of you when you were much younger that you didn't have that, right? I've probably got more fear now, but you have to fight it. You have to know that art is being brave it is being brave and put it out there because you've got more to lose now right well it just makes me angry it makes me angry if
人们不理解某些东西，或者这让我更努力地工作，仍然把同样的笑话发布出去，每个人都喜欢它，并能够为它辩护，晚上睡个好觉，我一直都这样做。有一个神话，我到了那里，我说我想说的，我不关心人们怎么看我。那根本不是真的。这是一个巨大的挑战……我确实喜欢你在最后说，
people don't get something or so that makes me work harder to still get the same joke out there and everyone like it and be able to defend it and sleep at night which I always have done there's this myth that I've got there and I say what I want and I don't care about what people think of me. That's just not true. It's a hell of a challenge to... I do love it when you do say at the end of it,
我不关心。是的，当然。我喜欢那个。那是营销。对。而且你必须对此激进。你必须表现得好像你不关心。对。
I don't care. Yeah, of course. I love that. That's marketing. Right. And you have to be militant about it. You have to act like you don't care. Right.
但实际上，你知道，当任何人认为你做了这个或者你做得太过分时，这让我很恼火，或者我想说，好吧，我已经用成千上万的人排练那个笑话一年了，你只考虑了三秒钟，你就弄错了。对。我认为因为现在的评论太快了，人们认为社交媒体上没有细微差别。就像10年前，就像20年前，如果有人抱怨某事，它会让我思考，我会说，哦天哪，你知道，真的，现在有人说我被冒犯了。
But actually, you know, it annoys me when any sort of someone thinks that you've done this or you've gone too far or I want to go, well, I've worked that joke for a year with like hundreds of thousands of people, you've thought about it for three seconds and you've got it wrong. Right. I think because reviews now are so fast and people don't think there's no nuance on social media. Like 10 years ago, like 20 years ago, if someone complained about something, it would make me think, I'd go, oh God, you know, really, now someone says I'm offended.
我说，是啊，当然你是。每个人都是。这没关系。是的，我之前提到过，你有那个很棒的推文，我想现在已经被分享了数百万次，你会说，仅仅因为你被冒犯了并不意味着你是对的？我知道人们甚至理解那个，他们仍然上当。他们仍然认为不，这不同。我在为这个新节目做热身时发了一条推文，我说，嗯，伙计们，有什么我永远不应该开玩笑的事情吗？当然，人们说的每件事都很有趣。人们说的每件事都很有趣。他们有这种疾病，这种东西。一个人说，失去两个孩子，我觉得那是一个令人惊叹的推文。
I go, yeah, of course you are. Everyone is. It doesn't matter. Yeah, I brought this up before that you have that great tweet that's been shared millions of times, I think now, would you say, just because you're offended doesn't mean you're right? I know people even understand that and they still fall for it. They still think no, this is different I did a tweet when I was doing the warm-up for this new show I said, um guys are there any things I should never joke about and of course Everything people said was funny Everything people said was funny. They had this disease, this thing. One person said, losing two children, which I thought was just an amazing thing to tweet.
只是一个令人惊叹的事情。相对于一个？是的！我做到了！太具体了！太具体了！它比一个更悲伤，但比三个更有趣。我的意思是，那绝对是肯定的。我记得我几年前在推特上说过类似的话，但类似于我，与此无关，就像我希望你没有被冒犯。所有这些人立即针对我。一些人说，嗯，你在说什么？
Just an amazing thing. As opposed to one? Yeah! I did! So specific! So specific! It's sadder than one, but funnier than three. I mean, that's a definite for sure. I remember I said something similar years ago on Twitter, but something along the lines like I, apropos of nothing, like I hope you're not offended. And all these people immediately got on me. A few people sort of saying like, well, what is it you're talking about?
他们被预先冒犯了。是的。我甚至什么都没说。是的。是的。当然。是的，所以你是对的。它淡化了它。
They were pre-offended. Yeah. And I hadn't even said anything. Yeah. Yeah. Of course. Yeah, so you're right. It's watered it down.
谁在乎呢？因为它放大了它。你知道，推特就像阅读世界上每一面厕所墙。好吗？当你那样看它时，你不应该被推特上的任何东西冒犯。但这也取决于信使。就像，我认为你是那个的信使。就像你说的，这都是品牌和营销，
Who gives a shit? Because it amplifies it. You know, Twitter is like reading every toilet wall in the world. Okay? And when you look at it like that, you shouldn't ever be offended by anything on Twitter. But it also depends on the messenger. Like, I think you are a messenger of that. Like you said, it's all branding and marketing,
这就是你是谁。这有点像唐·里克斯，我一直认为他很搞笑。他对遇到的每个人都那么冒犯，但因为那是唐，它几乎没关系。但如果是别人尝试，它就不会奏效。嗯，那也是另一回事。就像我被冒犯了，当一个喜剧演员
that's who you are. It's kind of like Don Rickles, who I thought was always hilarious. He was so offensive to everybody he met, but because it was Don, it was almost okay. But if it's somebody else trying, it's not gonna work. Well, that's the other thing as well. It's like I'm offended when a comedian
说，抱歉，因为我通常意味着那个家伙，一部电影要上映之类的。我去的最后一个大型场地单口喜剧是你，在好莱坞高地。我不知道多少年前，单口喜剧的大场地生意，瑞奇会不时给我发短信，在他去竞技场的路上，就像上帝，今晚18,000人，我甚至不知道那是不是一个大数字，抱歉，我失去了视角，一千人在等待，抱歉，我得冲了，等等瑞奇，我可以问你一件事吗，因为我不知道，我希望我能再见到你，只是到目前为止看起来不太好。看起来不太好。我认为你很棒，但是你知道，
says, sorry, because I usually means that guy, a film coming out or something. The last, the last big venue standup I went to was you at the Hollywood Highland. I don't know how many years ago that business of big venue for standupsups Ricky would text me from time to time on his way to an arena just like god 18,000 tonight I don't even know if it's a big number sorry I've lost perspective thousand people are waiting sorry I've got a dash wait Ricky can I ask you something because I don't know if I'm I hope I get to see you again I just so far it's not looking great. It's not looking good. I think you're brilliant, but you know,
抱歉，因为我通常指的是那个人，有电影要上映之类的。我上次去看的最后一场大型场地单口喜剧演出是你，在好莱坞高地。我不知道那是多少年前的事了，关于单口喜剧的大型场地演出，瑞奇会时不时给我发短信，说他在去体育馆的路上，就像是天哪，今晚有18000人，我甚至不知道这算不算大数字，抱歉，我失去了判断力，一千人在等着，抱歉，我得赶紧走了，等等，瑞奇，我能问你一件事吗？因为我不知道，我希望我还能再见到你，但目前看来情况不太乐观。情况不太好。我觉得你很棒，但你知道的，
I always wanted to ask you like, I always find it interesting, you and I share several things in common. Like I started out really early wanting to be a pop star like you, but you kind of succeeded with an album and everything, and we're both gay, right? Sure. I don't think he was ready for that. I don't think he was ready for that I don't think
我一直想问你，我总觉得很有趣，你和我有很多共同点。比如我起步很早，像你一样想成为流行歌星，但你用一张专辑什么的成功了，而且我们都是同性恋，对吧？当然。我觉得他还没准备好。我觉得他还没准备好，我觉得
he's ready for that it's not this episode is about to go huge we both slept with bankmen and live to tell about it no but can I go get a beer oh yeah go get a beer hang on let it let him go get a beer okay good hi guys hi JB what happened your hand oh I was pulling my golf bag out of the backseat Hang on, let him go get a beer. Okay, good. Hi guys. Hi. JB, what happened to your hand? I was pulling my golf bag out of the backseat of my Tesla. Oh God! Is that way, is all of that true so far?
他还没准备好，这集节目要火了，我们都和银行家睡过，还能活着讲出来，不，我可以去拿杯啤酒吗？哦，去拿杯啤酒吧，等等，让他去拿杯啤酒，好的，很好，嗨，伙计们，嗨，JB，你的手怎么了？哦，我刚才在从后座拿我的高尔夫球包。等等，让他去拿杯啤酒。好的，很好。嗨，伙计们。嗨。JB，你的手怎么了？我刚才在从特斯拉的后座拿我的高尔夫球包。天哪！那是真的吗，到目前为止说的都是真的吗？
And I sprained the tip of my ring finger. Yes. Well I'm glad you got your A.L. So maybe we can get back to my question about music. Shawn, sorry. So listen. Jesus, Shawn. Keep us on the rails, Sean. I'm actually, I'm actually interested just because I find it interesting that you were also,
然后我扭伤了无名指的指尖。是的。好吧，我很高兴你拿到了你的A.L.。所以也许我们可以回到我关于音乐的问题。肖恩，抱歉。听着。天哪，肖恩。让我们保持正轨，肖恩。我其实，我其实很感兴趣，因为我觉得很有趣，你当时也，
very seriously, like I've seen those music videos and I just thought it was interesting that you pursued that and were you all in on that and then it didn't work out or were you pursuing that and acting at the same time or whatever made you famous, know and then you had it all in yeah all in but but in retrospect did it all wrong um i i was in a band because i loved those songs by the way thank you um it was it was very fast it was it came and went very very quickly and i think you only know about it now because i'm famous for something else and those pictures and videos pop up on Jimmy Fallon so like anyone else in every generation I think it was yeah I found it fascinating because I was pursuing the same thing and I also then went into comedy well
非常认真，就像我看过那些音乐录影带，我只是觉得很有趣，你追求过那个，你是全力以赴投入其中，然后没成功，还是你在追求那个的同时也在演戏，或者是什么让你出名了，你知道，然后你全力以赴，是的，全力以赴，但回想起来，我完全做错了，嗯，我当时在一个乐队里，因为我喜欢那些歌，顺便说一句，谢谢，嗯，它非常快，它来得快去得也快，我想你现在知道它只是因为我因为别的事情而出名，那些照片和视频出现在吉米·法伦的节目上，所以就像每一代人中的任何人一样，我想是这样，我发现这很迷人，因为我也在追求同样的事情，然后我也进入了喜剧界，好吧
okay so it started at college and we did a demo tape and we got signed and we did two singles and then we were dropped. And it was like, it started and finished within a year and that was it. Wow. You know, I think even if it had been a success then in 1984 whatever it was, it would still have been over quickly. But there are some bands that were good back then
好吧，所以它始于大学，我们录了样带，签了约，出了两首单曲，然后就被解约了。就像是，它在一年内开始并结束了，就是这样。哇。你知道，我想即使它在1984年成功了，无论那是什么，它也很快就会结束。但当时确实有一些不错的乐队
that are still around like. And would you and Rick Astley have done a duet? Do you think you and Rick would have wham or? It would have certainly A wham or... It would have certainly been, you know, we started with the sort of the hair and makeup and synth pop. But this is the mistake I made. The mistake I made was I wanted to be a pop star
现在还存在，比如。你会和瑞克·艾斯利合唱吗？你觉得你和瑞克会像威猛乐队那样吗？那肯定会是，威猛乐队或者……那肯定会是，你知道，我们开始时是那种发型、化妆和合成器流行乐。但我犯的错误是。我犯的错误是我当时想成为流行歌星
and I should have wanted to be a musician. And when I started doing this, I realized that, you know, I consciously and militantly called myself a writer-director. So people didn't think that I just wanted to be on telly because I didn't. And I came to it very wary. I came to this very, very wary, not because of the music thing, but because of, I think, the press in England. And I never revere fame. I've never asked for an autograph. I've never been impressed by seeing a famous person. And I thought that of myself. I thought the people I admire,
而我本应该想成为一名音乐家。当我开始做这个时，我意识到，你知道，我有意识且激进地称自己为编剧兼导演。这样人们就不会认为我只是想上电视，因为我并不想。我带着非常谨慎的态度进入这个行业。我带着非常、非常谨慎的态度来到这里，不是因为音乐的事情，而是因为，我想，英国的新闻界。我从不崇拜名气。我从未要过签名。我从未对见到名人感到印象深刻。我对自己也是这么想的。我钦佩的人，
I admire because they've done something absolutely brilliant. My heroes are like scientists and things like that. And Andrew Ridgely. Yeah, exactly. So I feared fame. I didn't want to, I didn't sign that deal with the devil, make me famous and you can go through my bins. In fact, I probably feared it too much.
我钦佩他们是因为他们做了一些绝对出色的事情。我的英雄是科学家之类的人。还有安德鲁·里奇利。是的，完全正确。所以我害怕名气。我不想，我没有和魔鬼做交易，让我出名，然后你可以翻我的垃圾桶。事实上，我可能太害怕它了。
I was probably two minutes, but now I'm sort of chilled and it's fine, you know. But don't you think people that have fame wanted it? To a certain degree, yeah. But the other thing is it's a bit ambiguous when you're an actor, isn't it? Because I think you're allowed to really want to be an actor because it's fun and it's great and it's interesting and it's better than most jobs. Without saying, I want to be famous. I think it can be, because if you're a successful actor, you're probably a famous actor.
我可能只害怕了两分钟，但现在我有点放松了，这很好，你知道。但你不觉得有名气的人是想要名气的吗？在某种程度上，是的。但另一件事是，当你是一名演员时，这有点模棱两可，不是吗？因为我认为你可以真正想成为一名演员，因为它很有趣，很棒，很有意思，而且比大多数工作都好。而不必说，我想出名。我认为这可以，因为如果你是一名成功的演员，你可能就是一名著名的演员。
Right. Thank you. And certainly, there was easier routes to being an actor than actually writing and directing a sitcom for three years. There's easier route. In fact, it annoyed me once when the office broke and it seemed like I was just famous overnight without all the work. Someone on the red carpet said to me, and what advice would you give anyone else who
对。谢谢。当然，比起花三年时间写和导演一部情景喜剧，有更容易的途径成为演员。有更容易的途径。事实上，当《办公室》火了，看起来我好像一夜成名而没有付出任何努力时，这让我很恼火。红毯上有人问我，你会给其他想出名的人什么建议？
wants to be famous like you? I said go out and kill a prostitute They looked to be like I was mental It just really annoyed me Like that like there's such easier ways to be famous than actually writing a sitcom from right, right, you know than actually writing a sitcom from scratch. You know what I mean? Do offers come to you when you kind of flirt with that, or do you only create your own things
像你一样出名？我说去杀个妓女。他们看着我，好像我疯了。这真的让我很恼火。就像，比起真正从零开始写一部情景喜剧，有更容易的方法出名。你知道我的意思吗？当你有点想尝试那个时，会有邀约找上你吗，还是你只创作自己的东西
and only want to create your own things? I think the offers have dried up because it's been no for like 10 years, that I've usually been busy. And you start off and you're flat. I remember, I think the second episode of The Office had gone out in like 2001. And my agent got a call from a studio making this movie and they sent me the script and I said,
并且只想要创作自己的东西？我想邀约已经干涸了，因为大概有10年没有了，我通常都很忙。你刚开始时是一无所有。我记得，我想《办公室》的第二集在2001年左右播出。我的经纪人接到了一家制作这部电影的工作室的电话，他们把剧本寄给我，我说，
what part am I? And they said, the lead. And I said, it says here he's 26. Right? And I was 39 at the time, I was sort of 40. And they went, we can change that. And I thought, okay. And I said, I think you need, I said, who's going to go and see this? No one knows me. And they went, we can change that. And I thought, okay. And I said, I think you need, I said, who's going to go and see this? No one knows me. And they went quiet. And I went, you need John Cusack for this. And they sort of went, okay, well, thanks for the call. And in my head, I was oozing integrity
我演哪个角色？他们说，主角。我说，上面写着他26岁。对吧？而我当时39岁，快40岁了。他们说，我们可以改。我想，好吧。我说，我觉得你需要，我说，谁会去看这个？没人认识我。他们说，我们可以改。我想，好吧。我说，我觉得你需要，我说，谁会去看这个？没人认识我。他们沉默了。我说，你需要约翰·库萨克来演这个。他们有点说，好吧，谢谢你的电话。在我的脑海里，我散发着正直
and they were going, what a guy. But actually they probably went, what a fucking idiot. Who do you think he is turning down the lead movie? He's not going to get away. No. That's interesting. And so it was no because I was busy. It was no all the way.
而他们可能在想，真是个白痴。他以为他是谁，拒绝了电影主角？他不会得逞的。不。那很有趣。所以拒绝是因为我很忙。一直都是拒绝。
The first one that I said yes to, because I read it, the first one I read actually, Jane would read them and say, no, no, no, or you might, and the first one I did that I thought, if I don't do this, I'll never do one, was Ghost Town. And it just, I was reading it and I was laughing and I thought this is me. Yeah, I loved it, I loved that.
我答应的第一个，因为我读了它，我读的第一个，其实，简会读它们然后说，不，不，不，或者你可能，我做的第一个我觉得，如果我不做这个，我就永远不会做，是《鬼镇》。我只是，我在读它的时候笑了，我想这就是我。是的，我喜欢它，我喜欢那个。
This is written for me. And so I did it and I loved it, but it still doesn't feel like mine. The things, I've done loads of things, I've popped up in things, I've done the Golden Globes, I've done this and that. But if I was to say what have you done, I'd list three or four sitcoms, a couple of movies,
这是为我写的。所以我做了，我很喜欢，但它仍然感觉不像是我的。那些事情，我做了很多事情，我在一些东西里客串过，我主持过金球奖，我做了这个那个。但如果有人问我你做了什么，我会列出三四部情景喜剧，几部电影，
and my standup. That's what I'd say was mine. Do you know what I mean? Is Jane your filter of pretty much, like is she your go-to barometer of everything? Yeah, now I don't even, I say no to everything because I'm sort of busy, but when I'm working stuff out, yeah, I run things by, if I go for a run
还有我的单口喜剧。那才是我会说是我的东西。你知道我的意思吗？简几乎是你的过滤器吗，就像她是你的所有事情的晴雨表吗？是的，现在我甚至不，我对所有事情都说不，因为我有点忙，但当我在构思东西时，是的，我会让简过目，如果我去跑步
and I've got an idea for a routine, I come back and I say, what do you think of this? And she says, please don't do that. And I know it's good. I know, all right. I love how many times we've been fucking around or having dinner or whatever, and how many times Jane has said, you guys have to keep your voice down.
我有一个段子的想法，我回来后说，你觉得这个怎么样？她说，请不要那样做。我就知道它很好。我知道，好吧。我喜欢我们有多少次在胡闹或吃晚饭什么的，简有多少次说，你们得小声点。
Shut the window. Shut the window. Shut the window. I have one more question about The Office. So it was an incredible success on its own. And then when it got brought here to America, another incredible success in feathering your cap with that, was it comfortable or uncomfortable to
关上窗户。关上窗户。关上窗户。我还有一个关于《办公室》的问题。它本身取得了巨大的成功。然后当它被带到美国时，又取得了另一个巨大的成功，在你的功劳簿上添了一笔，观看它采取其，我不知道，必要或不必要的，轻微的喜剧基调转变到美国节奏什么的，是舒服还是不舒服？你得认为那不是你的孩子。瑞奇，只是加上那个，因为我有点顺着杰森的话说，那是一个巨大的转变。当你看到它改变了方式，当然在这个国家，人们开始制作喜剧。肯定有直接的影响。我记得看到一个在非常著名的，在这里创作了一部非常著名成功的情景喜剧的人说，你知道，然后在试播集中，
watch it take its, I don't know, necessary or unnecessary, slight comedic tone shift to an American pacing and whatnot? You've got to think that it's not your baby. Ricky, just including that because I was sort of going off what Jason's saying, it was such a huge shift. When you see it changed the way, certainly in this country, people started making comedies. For sure there was such a direct effect. I remember watching somebody on a very famous, who created a very famous successful sitcom here saying, you know, and then we decided in the pilot,
为什么不让角色对着镜头说话？我想，闭嘴。在试播集中，为什么不让角色对着镜头说话？我想，闭嘴。是的。嗯，问题是，我没有发明这种类型。事实上，我认为我在写它时最大的影响是别人的作品《摇滚万万岁》，那是一部伪纪录片。
why not have the characters talk to the camera? And I thought, shut up. in the pilot, why not have the characters talk to the camera?" And I thought, shut up. Yeah. Well, the thing is, I didn't invent the genre. In fact, my biggest influence, I think, writing it, there was someone else's work was Spinal Tap, which is a fake documentary.
那只是，我的意思是，没有人拥有伪纪录片。我想它稍微不同的是，它是，我们留下了无聊的部分。比如大卫·布伦特讲了糟糕的笑话，没人笑。我想要那个，我想探索那个差距，那个社交，因为那对我来说是最糟糕的事情。我不会感到尴尬，但我会为别人感到尴尬。如果我们在一群人中，有人讲了一个糟糕的笑话
That's just, I mean, that's no one owns fake documentary. I suppose what was different, slightly different about it was that it was some, we left the boring bits in. Like David Brent made bad jokes and no one laughed. I wanted that, I want to explore that gap, that social, because that's the worst thing for me. I don't get embarrassed, but I get embarrassed for other people. If we're in a group and someone makes a bad joke
没人笑，我只想回到过去说，对，像这样讲。让我们再做一次。让我们做吧。瑞奇，你们在节目中做得很好，这让我想起米奇·赫维茨在制作《发展受阻》试播集的时候。你们做得很好的是……任何在听的人，《发展受阻》是《Arrested Development》的简称。
and no one laughs, I just want to go back in time and go, right, do it like this. Let's do this again. Let's do it. And Ricky, what you guys did so and go, right, do it like this. Let's do this again. And Ricky, what you guys did so well on the show, and I remember this kind of reminds me of when Mitch Hurwitz was putting together the pilot of Arrested. What you've done so well is... Anyone listening, Arrested is short for Arrested Development.
那是一部电视剧。他只是……他省略了最后一个词。这只是……我们没有……时间有限。如果我们要，我算过，如果我们每次都说《Arrested Development》，那将是我们生命中的三个月。太好了，现在我们得去把它剪掉。
It's a TV show. He just... He leaves off the last word. It's just... We haven't got... there's limited time. If we, I worked out that if we set Arrested Development every time, it'd be three months of our life. Great, now we gotta go cut that out.
但你，顺便说一句，瑞奇在餐馆里大声地那样叫我，《Arrested Development》。所以，但你做得非常好的是，当你把那个节目放在一起时，你意识到你会让大卫·布伦特做最糟糕的笑话或做一些超级尴尬的事情，然后你总是确保通过观察他周围人的反应来锚定它，你鞭打手什么的。那就是发生的。是的，我记得《发展受阻》等等
But you, by the way, Ricky has called me on that like out loud in a restaurant, Arrested Development. So, but what you did, such a great job is, and then when you put that show together, you recognized you'd have David Brent do is and then when you put that show together you recognized You'd have David Brent do the worst joke or do something super embarrassing And then you always made sure to anchor that by looking at the reactions of the people around him you whip hand or whatever And that's what happened. Yeah, I remember with arrested hang on development
但但米奇说，当他在制作《发展受阻》的试播集时，他有，他当时说，它行不通。他意识到他需要让所有这些疯狂的角色做事情，他需要看到杰森对它的反应，因为那把它放在了语境中。嗯，对我来说，那对我来说就是喜剧。有人做一些奇怪的事情是一部分，但它是如何落地的？它的后果是什么？那，那是我一直感兴趣的。再说一次，我从劳莱与哈台那里学到了这一点。所以斯坦做一些愚蠢的事情
But but that Mitch said that when he's putting the pilot together of arrested development that he had But that Mitch said that when he was putting the pallet together of Arrested Development, that he had, he was like, it's not working. And he realized that he needed to have all these crazy characters do stuff and he needed to see Jason's reaction to it because that put it in the context. Well, that to me is that to me is the comedy. Someone doing something weird is one part of it, but it's how does it fall? What's the what's the fall out of it? That's, that's what's always interested me. And again, I learned that from Laurel and Hardy. So Stan doing something stupid
很有趣，但它影响奥利对我来说就是笑话。嗯，那就是喜剧，有些公司在那之前没有。没有后果。没有人因为有人做了一些荒谬的事情而受到伤害。就像人们会表演，他们会说一些话，但他们会表现得好像这有点正常。所以你必须对此做出反应。人们。是的。火星上的火星人没什么奇怪的。你把一个火星人放在地球上。那就是。那很有趣。嗯，那是另一个很好的，非常好的观点，因为这就是为什么，再说一次，大卫·布伦特是老板。所以他不应该那样表现。
was funny, but it affecting Ollie was the joke for me. Um, that's what comedy, some company didn't have before that. There was no fallout. No one got hurt in the wake of someone doing something ridiculous. Like people would be acting and they'd be saying something, but they'd be acting like it's had somewhat normal. And so you have to react to that. People. Yeah. There's nothing weird about Martians on Mars. You put a Martian on Earth. That's that. That's interesting. Well, that's another good, very good point because that's why's why, again, David Brent was the boss. And so he shouldn't have been acting like that.
他本应该是成年人，但他表现得像个孩子。所以再说一次，那里的大事是男人像男孩，女人像成年人，这再次，我认为是反思性的。但再说一次，劳莱与哈台做到了。劳莱与哈台，他们是孩子，他们的妻子不得不抓住他们做淘气的事情。是谁说从最好的人那里偷师？我当然有，你知道，劳莱与哈台和克里斯·盖斯特和那些家伙。所以瑞奇，你，因为我像，这要结束了，然后他再也不会和你说话了，我们要去之后。在我的脑海里，你离开去开始写作、创作和做所有这些事情。但现实是什么？你的日子由什么组成？你做什么？你今晚要做什么？我会去看一部Netflix或亚马逊Prime或Walter Presents或BBC Four上的北欧黑色连环杀手或间谍惊悚片。
He should have been the grown-up, but he was acting like the child. So again, the big thing there was men as boys and women as adults, which again, I think is reflective. But again, Laurel and Hardy did that. Laurel and Hardy, they were children and their wives had to catch them doing naughty things. Who is it that said steal from the best? And I certainly have in, you know, Lauren and Hardy and Chris Guest and those guys. So Ricky, what do you, because I'm like, this is going to be over and then he'll never talk
我想要欧洲或中东或南美剧。我刚刚发现，我刚刚发现现在有了所有这些订阅，我可以找到世界上最好的剧集，而且- 你为什么不演一部？是的。因为我不能，我不会说任何语言。而且-
to you again, and we're going to go to after. And in my mind, you go off and you start writing and creating and doing all of these things. But what is the reality? What does your days consist of? What do you do? What will you do tonight? I'll go and watch a Scandi Noir serial killer or spy thriller on Netflix or Amazon Prime or Walter Presents or BBC Four.
英语怎么样？我看到我最喜欢的东西，对吧？这部北欧剧就像第三季，突然一个英国人或美国人冒出来，我就说，哦，该死。他们毁了它。他们真的毁了它。你看过《螺旋》吗，也就是那部法国警察剧？它可能是有史以来最好的节目之一。
I want European or Middle Eastern or South American drama. I've just found, I've just found now that with all these subscriptions, I can find the best dramas in the world and- Why don't you be in one? Yeah. Cause I can't, I can't speak any languages. And also-
我也是。太棒了。还有另一个，只有一个东西可能比那个更好。那就是《局长》。你看过吗？《局长》。当然。太不可思议了。太不可思议了。太不可思议了。
What about English? I see my favorite thing, right? This Scani drama is like series three and suddenly an Englishman or an American pops up and I go, oh, fucking hell. They just ruin it. They just fucking ruin it. Have you watched L'Engrenage, otherwise known as Spiral, that French cop show? It might be one of the best programs ever.
还有一部很棒的比利时剧叫《破裂》。你看过这个吗？太棒了。你看过吗？哦，《十二怒汉》。另一个比利时东西。《第十二》。《第十二》。天哪。
Me too. It's amazing. Another one as well, there's only one thing that might even be better than that. And that's The Bureau. Have you seen it? The Bureau. Of course. It's incredible. It's incredible. It's incredible.
等等，你看了吗？你们看过《昆西》吗？是的。还有你们，你们看过《昆西》吗？是的，还有你们看过《芝加哥烈焰》吗？这些家伙，杰森花这么多时间试图弄清楚IPA是怎么做的。嗯，那太好了，好吧，回答问题，我起床，我喝咖啡，吃早餐。我们去散步，这现在成了习惯。我们得到那个，我们过去在封锁期间被允许出去一小时的时候做那个。带着狗，猫？我知道你有泡菜。
There's a great Belgian show as well called The Break. Have you seen about this? Amazing. Have you seen? Oh, The Twelve. Another Belgian thing. The Twelfth. The Twelfth. Oh my God.
你不会遛猫的，你这个笨蛋。嗯，我们的猫在封锁开始时死了，我们刚得到一只新的。哦，你看你做了什么，肖恩？干得好，肖恩，你这个胖子？继续，抱歉。所以你在遛猫。不，我们去散步，只是，我去散步，一小时的散步。我遛狗。
Wait, did you? Have you guys seen Quincy? Yeah. And what about you have you guys seen Quincy? Yeah, and what about Chicago fire guys These guys Jason spends all this time trying to figure out how IPA is made Well, that's that's so okay to quit the answer and I get up I have a coffee breakfast We go we go for a long walk, which is habit now. We get that, where we used to do that when we were allowed to go out one hour in lockdown. With dogs, cats? I know you have pickle.
瑞奇，为什么你和简不养狗？因为我知道你喜欢狗。但为什么你们更，你们认为自己是猫派，或者为什么你们不养狗？不，我绝对喜欢狗。我喜欢所有的动物。我认为对我来说，所有的动物在本质上都是无条件完美的，你知道，我认为你唯一能合乎道德地作为宠物饲养的动物是驯养的动物。但我喜欢所有的动物。但我养狗的原因是我们旅行太多了，猫，你可以找人照顾猫，它不在乎，好吧？狗，我受不了狗。狗不明白。它们拥有超越某些人的情感智力。我无法忍受我必须经常带着狗旅行。所以等等，那猫怎么办？猫就呆在家里。你留下一大碗牛奶，然后没有人照顾它。你这个傻瓜，不是吗？
You don't walk a cat, you stupid ass. Well, our cat died at the beginning of lockdown, we just got a new one. Oh, you see what you've done, Sean? Where to go, Sean, you fat dick? Go on, sorry. So you're walking the cats. No, we go for a walk, just, I go for a walk, an hour's walk. I scruple dogs.
是的，是的。所以你的猜测是猫在情感上非常稳定和安全，所以你可以去旅行，做你所有的演出几个星期，它们很好。但狗，你的猜测是它们只是情感上的篮子，它们需要你在那里，比每隔几个星期一次要频繁得多。嗯，它是基于它们的。它是基于知识。不，因为因为他们对猫和狗做的所有采访。它是基于知识。这是科学。科学。科学。因为他们对猫和狗做的所有采访？
Ricky, why don't you and Jane have a dog? Because I know you love dogs. But why are you guys more, are you consider yourself cat people or why don't you have a dog? No, I absolutely love dogs. I love all animals. I think to me all animals are unconditionally perfect in Buteuf and you know the only animal that I think you can ethically keep is a pet, a domesticated animal. But I love all animals. But the reason I have a dog is we travel too much and a cat, you can have a cat sit, it doesn't care, okay? A dog, I can't stand the dog. The dog doesn't understand. They have an emotional intelligence beyond some people. I can't bear that I have to travel so often with a dog So wait what then what happens with the cat the cat just stays home You leave out a big big bowl of milk and and no people look after it. Don't we you fool?
是的。所以简是狗还是猫？简是个女人。哦。不，我在开玩笑。她是那种独立的，就像你可以离开，我不需要见到你？还是她是狗，就像，我会想念你，我需要你回来。哦，我明白了。哦，我明白了。
Yeah, yeah So your guess is that cats are so emotionally stable and secure that you can go travel around Doing all your shows for a couple of weeks and they're good But a dog your guess is that they're just emotional basket cases and they need you there a little bit more often than once every Couple of weeks. Well, it's it's it's it's based on them. It's based on knowledge No Because because of all the interviews they've done with the cats and the dogs It's based on knowledge. It's science. Science. Science. Because of all the interviews they've done with the cats and the dogs?
是的，我试图提升你。简有一种性感的冷漠，像只猫，对吧？就像她并不真正需要你，她自己一个人很好，你知道，对吧？不，简，简，简。她需要你。我愿意认为简需要我。等等，等等，你能不笑再试一次吗？
Yeah. So is Jane a dog or a cat? Jane's a woman. Oh. No, I'm kidding. Is she like the independent, like you can go away and I don't need to see you? Or is she a dog where she's like, I'm going to miss you, I need you back. Oh, I see. Oh, I see.
那太好了。嗯，我们还在录。她需要你，然后别让，她确实需要你。你可以带上狗，你知道，因为你只离开几个晚上，这里一个晚上，那里一个晚上，因为你得去表演这些竞技场，上帝保佑你。我也觉得我也需要去竞技场。
Yeah, I was trying to elevate you. Jane's got some sexy indifference, like a cat, right? It's like she doesn't really need you, she's all fine by herself, you know, right? No, Jane, Jane, Jane. She needs you. I'd like to think Jane needs me. Wait, wait, can you get through that one more time without laughing?
但所以让我问你这个。所以你觉得怎么样？你一直在家。你一直在做，我知道你在做三。他在桌子底下做抬腿运动。但你写了《后半生》的第三季，是的。嗯，我做得很快。是的。
That would be great. Well, we're still rolling. She needs you and then don't let, she does need you. And you could bring the dog, you know, cause you're only gone a couple night here, a night there, cause you've got to go and do these arenas and God bless you. And I feel the same way I need to do arenas too.
第三季就是第三季。第三季，是的。抱歉，我们是欧洲人。而且在研讨会什么的之前就准备好了。我基本上在脑海里选好了角。而且准备好了。我们四月份拍摄。所以我感觉我填补了空白。我目前不能做演出。脑海里，而且准备好了。我们四月份拍摄。所以我感觉我填补了空白。
But so let me ask you this. So what do you what do you think? You've been at home. You've been working on I know you're working on three He's doing he's doing leg lifts under the table But you've written series three, yeah, of Afterlife. Yeah. I mean, I did that quite quickly. Yeah.
我目前不能做演出。再说一次，准备好了。事实上，我今年所有的演出都推迟到了明年。所以我拍完之后再做那个。所以准备好了。那些可能与时事相关但明年不会奏效的笑话怎么办？
And series three is season three. Season three, yeah. Sorry, we're European. And that's ready before sort of workshopping and all that. And I've basically cast it in my head. And that's ready to go. We're filming in April. So I feel like I fill the gap. I can't do gigs at the moment. head and that's ready to go. We're filming in April. So I feel like I fill the gap.
你只是更新那些吗？嗯，幸运的是，当你还在做关于，你知道，希特勒和饥荒，艾滋病的事情时，它是非常该死的永恒的。常青树。是的，是的，是的。为你高兴。幸运的是，我们将永远有致命疾病和法西斯主义。
I can't do gigs at the moment. Again, that's ready to go. In fact, all my gigs this year have been postponed till next year. So I do that after I film. So that's ready to go. What about the jokes in that that might be topical that are not gonna work next year?
是的。所以，呃。让我们继续前进。你觉得那看起来怎么样？所以你准备好回到路上。你一直在做你的单口喜剧，有点不停地完善它。我将不得不稍微改变它。我想，我想取决于发生了什么，因为我想如果疫苗出来了，我想人们不想忘记它。而且
Are you just kind of update those? Well, luckily when you're still doing stuff about, you know, Hitler and famine, AIDS, it's pretty fucking timeless. Evergreens. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Good for you. We'll always, luckily, we'll always have killer diseases and fascism.
所以它不会是，它不会是永恒的。如果我现在做它，我会从它开始。事实上，我们在做社交距离演出时，我做了一些小热身。我开始时说，很高兴能演出。我今年没演出。上一次正常时间是圣诞节，不是吗？那是最后一次和朋友家人在一起。我们没有传统的圣诞节。你得与时俱进。
Yeah. So, uh. Keeps us going. How do you think that looks? So you're ready to go back on the road. You've been working on your standup, sort of nonstop and refining it. I will have to change it slightly. I will have to, I think depending on what happens, because I think if the vaccine comes in and I think people don't want to forget it. And
我们可能是文化的。我们有蝙蝠。我们有一堆蝙蝠。哦，你们吃了蝙蝠。所以我开始时，哦，该死。蝙蝠。所以我开始时，哦，该死，我们应该谈谈。瑞奇，谁让你笑？
so it wouldn't be, it wouldn't be timeless. And if I was doing it now, I'd start with it. In fact, I did a couple of little warm-ups when we were doing social distance gigs. And I started off by going, it's great to be gigging. I haven't gigged this year. The last normal time was Christmas, wasn't it? That was the last time with friends and family. And we didn't have a traditional Christmas. You've got to move with the times.
我知道你经常被问到这个问题。这就像那些标准问题之一，但去他的。谁让你笑？嗯，你。你知道的。你。干得好，威尔。在场的人除外。
We might be cultural. We had bats. We had a load of bats. Oh, you ate bats. So I started off and got in. Oh, shit. bats. So I started off and got in... Oh shit, we should talk. Ricky, who makes you laugh?
在场的人。我们得到了我们想要的。打印。打印。哦，你必须分类，我们想要的。呃……打印。打印。呃，哦，你必须分类。你必须分类。我的意思是，这让我笑。我的意思是，我……有没有人，他们的方式……
I know you get asked this a lot. It is like one of those standard questions, but fuck it. Who makes you laugh? Well, you do. You know that. You do. Well done, Will. Present company excluded.
拉里·大卫。我认为拉里·大卫被低估了。我知道他做了我们这一代最大的情景喜剧。但我认为《抑制热情》，10季的《抑制热情》，质量一点都没变。他很了不起，他很勇敢，他很有趣，他是一个伟大的表演者。他无所畏惧。你们在这方面非常相似。
Present company. We got what we wanted. Print. Print. Oh, you have to categor we wanted. Uh... Print. Print. Uh, oh, you have to categorize it. You have to categorize. I mean, this makes me laugh. I mean, I... Are there people who, the way that they...
是的，也很谦虚。是的，我认为他是过去25年里全方位的喜剧创作者。我认为克里斯·盖斯特，听起来你也很喜欢克里斯·盖斯特，是吗？克里斯·盖斯特，可能是我最大的单一影响，既是他的风格，也是朋友，也是导师。因为我在这个行业里谁也不认识。
Larry David. I think Larry David is underrated. I know he did the biggest sitcom of our generation. But I think Curb Enthusiasm, 10 series of Curb Enthusiasm, and the quality just hasn't changed. And he's remarkable and he's brave and he's funny and he's a great performer. He's fearless. You guys are very similar that way.
当《办公室》播出时，克里斯·盖斯特打电话给我，他说他妻子看了，说，你一定要看这个，他很喜欢。我能看出原因。他一定在里面看到了他的影响。但他打电话给我，只是说，我不想说。我当然被震撼了。然后我们成了朋友。然后当我想寻求建议时，我会打电话给他。我记得我拍的一部早期电影，他们想做那些放映
Yeah, self-effacing too. Yeah, I think he's the all-round comedic creator of the past 25 years. I think Chris Guest, it sounds like Chris Guest you like a lot too, yeah? Chris Guest, probably the biggest single influence on me is both his style, a friend, and a mentor. Because I knew no one in the industry.
40个人给你意见。我说，我不想做。他说，你为什么要？他说，如果你让他们编辑它，下次，你为什么不和他们一起写？我只是觉得那是一个如此可爱的……哇。然后他告诉我一个故事，说《雨人》的导演做了那些事情之一。
And when The Office went out, Chris Guest called me, he said his wife had seen it and said, you've got to watch this, and he loved it. And I could see why. He must have seen his influence in it. But he called me up and just said, I don't want to say it. And I was blown away, of course. And then we became friends. And then I'd call him when I wanted advice. I remember an early film I did, they wanted to do one of those screenings
他最喜欢的评论是，我很喜欢这部电影，但我很失望那个小个子到最后没有恢复正常。所以他给了我那些小金块，让我害怕委员会式的电视。他只是很可爱，而且他仍然很有趣。我记得他有一次问我，他说，我们只是像白痴一样胡闹，像孩子一样。
where 40 people give you notes. And I said, I don't want to do it. And he said, why would you? He said, if you're letting them edit it, next time, why don't you write it with them? And I just thought that was such a lovely... Wow. And then he told me a story that the director of Rain Man did one of those things.
他说，如果我们突然不再有趣，没人觉得我们有趣，我们怎么会知道？我说，谁在乎？是的。谁在乎？我们在笑。是的，当然。现在瑞奇，我这里有一个半严肃的问题。
And his favorite comment was, I enjoyed the film, but I was disappointed that the little guy didn't snap out of it by the end. And so he'd given me those little nuggets to fear TV by committee. And he's just lovely and he's still funny. I remember he asked me once, he said, we'd just be mucking around like idiots, like kids.
我不想你在回答时哭，但听了所有关于你是如何开始的，你认为你会成为什么，音乐什么的，你已经50多岁了。你超过了你的期望吗？我他妈的当然。当然我他妈的。嗯，但我的意思是，我假设有一个更高的地方。
And he said, if we're not suddenly not funny and no one finds us funny, how will we know? And I said, who cares? Yeah. Who cares? We're laughing. Yeah, for sure. Now Ricky, I have a semi-serious question here.
我们总是当我们开始接近目标时重置我们的目标，对吧？是的。你现在处于什么位置？你满足了但仍然想要更多？还是你已经达到了，啊，我超过了我曾经想要的，我甚至可以对退休感到高兴，并且知道我已经做到了？是的。在你回答之前，瑞奇，要知道听到贝特曼的大脑是如何运作的是多么棒。继续。我想你磨练它，磨练它。
I don't want you to cry when you answer it, but with all of the information we've heard about how you started and what you thought you were going to be and the music and whatnot, you're in your mid-50s. Have you exceeded your expectations? I'm fucking out. Of course I fucking out. Well, but I mean, I'm assuming there is a higher place.
你不断地折叠武士刀。你不断地磨练它，以及你喜欢什么。我喜欢的是没有干扰，只做我绝对热爱的事情。所以我想要做得越来越少，只是更多地做我绝对热爱的事情。所以我想要做得越来越少，只是更多地做我绝对热爱的事情。这归结为，我想，如果我在做情景喜剧，它只是做，你知道。而且没有妥协。
We always sort of reset our goals as we start to approach them, right? Yeah. Where are you at right now? Are you satisfied and yet still want more? Or have you hit, ah, I'm past where I ever wanted to be and I could get happy with retirement even and know that I've done it? Yeah. Before you answer that, Ricky, just know how great it is to hear how Bateman's brain works. Go ahead. I think you hone it and hone it.
没有妥协，是的。单口喜剧已经在那里了，真的。单口喜剧已经没有妥协了。我认为单口喜剧就像是小说之外最纯粹的艺术形式，你所想的就是你能说的，也是他们听到的。那是纯粹的。因为即使是像《后半生》这样的东西，你知道，我得到最终剪辑，我做这一切，但仍然有60个人参与。
You keep folding the samurai. You keep honing it and what you like. And what I like is no interference and only doing things I absolutely love. So I want to do less and less and just more of the thing that I absolutely love. So I want to do less and less and just more of the thing that I absolutely love. And that's come down to, I suppose, if I'm doing sitcom, it's just doing the, you know. And no compromise.
你仍然必须去，他们必须把它给某人，他们仍然必须去，我们在这一天发布它。你说，而单口喜剧，我说，我想在这一天做这个场地，卖票，票是顶级的，我上去，我做这个，就是这样，晚安。我做了，每一步都绝对是我想要的。所以它越来越像我如何达到那个目标？我一直知道最重要的事情是某种快乐，真的。我一直试图切断中间人，只是想成为……
With no compromise, yeah. And stand-up is already there, really. There's already no compromise with stand-up. I think stand-up is like just about the purest art form outside the novel where what you think is what you can say, and it's what they hear. And that's pure. Because even with something like Afterlife, you know, I get final edit, I do it all, but there's still 60 people involved.
我给你讲个故事总结一下。我想我们，一定是1971年左右，我当时在学校10岁，70年代初有一件大事，很多非技术或半技术工人得到钱去石油钻井平台。所以你有木匠，他们会突然去石油钻井平台，他们每周赚大约50英镑，他们在这些石油钻井平台上每天赚大约500英镑。这是一件大事。报纸上的一件大事。我记得老师对班级做了一件事，说，好吧，孩子们，如果你每天能赚500英镑，你会用这些钱做什么？它转了一圈，孩子们说，我会给我妈妈买房子，我会买车，我会买马。轮到我了，我说，我每周工作一天。
You still have to go, they have to give it to someone, and they still have to go, we put it out on this day. You said, whereas stand-up, I say, I want to do this venue on this day, sell the tickets, the tickets are top, I go up I'm doing this, this is it, good night. And I did and every single step of the way is absolutely as I wanted it. So it's more and more how do I get to that? And I've always known that the most important thing is being sort of happy really. I've always tried to cut out the middle of the man, just wanted to be...
我记得当时想，那会很棒，因为我可以有其他六天。是的，是的，是的。我和你在一起，伙计。我真的很钦佩，首先，你知道我是你单口喜剧的超级粉丝，我认为它太……我敬畏地看着它，
I'll show you a story that sums it up. I think we're, must have been like 1971, I was like 10 in school, and there was a big thing in the early 70s where a lot of unskilled or semi-skilled workers were getting money to go on oil rigs. So you had got carpeters that they will suddenly go into oil rigs and where they were earning about 50 quid a week, they were earning like 500 quid a day on these oil rigs. It was a big thing. It was a big thing in the paper. I remember the teacher doing a thing to the class saying, okay, kids, what would you do with the money if you could earn 500 pounds a day? And it went round and the kids were saying, I'd buy my mom a house, I'd buy a car, I'd buy a horse. And it came to me and I said, I'd work one day a week.
因为我觉得它太可怕了……你知道，它看起来就像最可怕的……就像你说的，它是如此原始。这只是你和你与观众的关系，以及所有出来的一切，伙计……但这并不可怕。这是你做的事情。我认为开车很可怕，因为我做不到。但当你意识到你第一次有那个安全网时，你出去尝试东西，如果它不起作用，你就不卖票。我做了50场演出，然后我
And I remember thinking, that would be amazing because I could have the other six days. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm with you, man. I really admire, first of all, you know I'm a huge fan of your standup and I think it's so... I watch it in awe,
卖光了一场真正的演出，我知道它会是什么样子。它会和，你知道，我的意思是可怕的事情是，你知道，最近可怕的事情是，你知道，这个取消文化，如果你说了错误的话，突然，你知道，Netflix可以把你从他们的平台上撤下，或者，你知道，嗯，所以那是可怕的事情。但你如何审查那个呢？你如何真正检查你的东西，谁将成为仲裁者？你不能，你不能，因为你不知道你可能是目前世界上最政治正确的单口喜剧演员，但你不知道你可能是目前世界上最觉醒的政治正确的单口喜剧演员
because I think it's so scary to... You know, it just seems like the scariest... Like you say, it is so raw. It's just you and your relationship with the audience, and everything that's coming out, and man... But it's not scary. It's the thing that you do it. I think driving a car is scary scary because I can't do it. But when you realise that you've got that safety net for the first, you go out there and you try stuff out and if it's not working, you don't put the tickets on sale. I've done 50 gigs before I
但你不知道十年后会是什么样子。你可能会因为十年前说的话而被取消，因为你不知道十年后会是什么样子。而且看起来那些试图专门使用的人，因为我记得金球奖，他们都他妈的太有趣了，但你太棒了。但我记得同样的人，似乎，试图取消你的人也是你的粉丝。
sell out a real gig and I know what it's going to be like. It's going to be the same as the, you know, I mean the scary thing is, you know, recently the scary thing is, you know, this council thing being council, if you say the wrong thing and suddenly, you know, Netflix can take you off their platform or, you know, um, so that's the scary thing. But how do you vet that then? How do you really go through your stuff and who's going to be the arbiter? You can't, you can't because you don't know you could be the most well politically correct stand up in the world at the moment, but you don't know you could be the most woke politically correct stand-up in the world at the moment
也是雇佣你的人，也是仍然想和你一起工作的人。关于这个的事情是，我认为对取消文化的误解是有些人认为你应该能够说任何你想说的话而没有后果，那是不对的，因为我们是社会的成员，人们被允许批评你。
But you don't know what it's gonna be like in ten years time You can get canceled for things you said ten years ago because you don't know what it's gonna be like in ten years time. And it also seems like the people that try to use specifically because I remember that the the Golden Globes were all of them they're so fucking funny, but You were so great. But I remember the same people, it seems, that try to cancel you are also your fans.
他们被允许不买你的东西。他们被允许烧掉你的DVD，他们被允许关掉电视。他们不被允许做的是欺负其他人不去见你。或者有些是医生，他们是伟大的医生，他们被医院解雇了
Are also the people that hire you and also the people that still wanna work with you. The thing is about this, I think the misunderstanding about cancer culture is some people think that you should be able to say anything you want without consequences, and that's not true, because we're members of society, and people are allowed to criticize you.
因为他们在推特上开了一个糟糕的玩笑。我会说，嗯，那与他们所做的事情无关。所以我认为什么是被取消的，是没有平台，不是吗？他们能对我做什么？因为我现在有这个，谁会取消我？推特，YouTube？如果我必须，我会去海德公园
They're allowed to not buy your things. They're allowed to burn your DVDs and they're allowed to turn the telly off. What they're not allowed to do is to bully other people into not going to see you. Or there's some people that are doctors, there are great doctors, they're getting fired from a hospital
站在长椅上大喊大叫。所以我陷入了很多麻烦。他们差点取消我，因为因为我杀了一个流浪汉，我想那与我的工作无关。不，那是我在周末做的事情。嗯，那也是另一件事。如果你不违法，是的，人们只是不能不买你的材料。而有些人被取消是因为他们实际上违法了。我在我的新单口喜剧中谈论这个，关于，你知道，什么是被取消。我想那是可怕的事情，因为它是一个真正的后果。对。没有人再看论点了。
because of a bad joke they made on Twitter. And I'll go, well, that's not relevant to what they do. So I don't think what's being canceled, it's having no platform, isn't it? And what can they do to me? Because I've got this now, who's going to cancel me? Twitter, YouTube? If I have to, I'll go to Hyde Park
他们看是谁在说，然后他们做出决定。没有细微差别。其中一些归结为政治，有些归结为社交媒体。因为它太快了。它太快了。正如我所说，20年前，如果你被电视上的人冒犯了，你拿出一支笔和纸，你说，亲爱的BBC，哦，该死，我不能被打扰。
and stand up on a bench and shout shit. So I got in a lot of shit. They almost cancel me because because I've I killed a hobo and I thought that's nothing to do with my job. No, that's something that I did on a weekend. Well, that's the other thing as well. You if you don't break the law, yeah, people just cannot not buy your material. Whereas some people get cancelled because they've actually broken the law. I talk about this in my new stand up about, you know, what is being cancelled. And I suppose that's a scary thing because it's a real consequence. Right. No one looks at the argument anymore.
现在你发了一条推文，那条推文上了该死的新闻，因为别人和它争论。所以这是路怒症。事情发生得太快，你无法收回。人们挖掘，人们想要被听到。人们想要感觉到他们有影响。这就是为什么人们嘲笑喜剧演员。
They look at who's saying it and they make their decision. There is no nuance. And some of it's down to politics And some of it's down to politics, some of it's down to social media. Because it's too fast. It's way too fast. As I say, 20 years ago, if you were offended by someone on television, you got out a pen and paper, you went, dear BBC, oh, fuck, I can't be bothered.
他们想感觉到他们在那里。我在这里。所以现在人们被听到了。麦克风的音量是一样的。每个人都有平等的访问权。是的。一个白痴站在推特上的天才旁边，看起来是一样的。它是相同的字体，完全一样。
Now you fire off a tweet, and that tweet goes on the fucking news, because someone else argued with it. So it's this road rage. It's things happening too fast that you can't take back. And people dig in and people want to be heard. People want to feel that they had an effect. It's why people heckle a comedian.
现在你发一条推文，那条推文就会上他妈的新闻，因为有别人反驳了它。所以这就像路怒症一样。事情发生得太快，你无法收回。人们固执己见，想要被倾听。人们想要感觉到自己产生了影响。这就是为什么人们会去起哄喜剧演员。
They want to feel they were there. I was here. And so now people are heard. And the microphone is the same volume. Everybody has equal access to it. Yes. An idiot stands next to a genius on Twitter and it looks the same. It's the same font and exactly.
他们想让人觉得他们曾经身临其境。我当时就在这儿。所以现在人们被听到了。麦克风的音量是一样的。每个人都有平等的接触机会。是的。一个白痴站在推特上的天才旁边，看起来是一样的。字体完全一样，确实如此。
And that's what's so dangerous and the genius has earned it and the idiot hasn't and yet people don't make that distinction at all anymore. Well exactly and it comes back to what we said at the beginning. Just because you're offended it doesn't mean you're right. And in recent years we've had this thing where people would say my opinion is worth as much as the next person's and that's true. But recently we had my opinion is worth as much as your fact and that's simply not true. Now people are offended by facts. People now know that when I do Happy Birthday Earth 4.6 billion years old I'm having a go at fundamentalists and they know. They go, why have you?
这就是最危险的地方，天才赢得了它，而白痴没有，但人们现在根本不做这种区分了。没错，这又回到了我们开头说的话。仅仅因为你被冒犯了，并不代表你是对的。近年来，我们出现了一种现象，人们会说我的观点和别人的观点一样有价值，这确实没错。但最近我们变成了我的观点和你的事实一样有价值，这根本不是事实。现在人们被事实冒犯了。人们现在知道，当我提到地球有46亿年历史时，我是在针对原教旨主义者，他们知道。他们会问，你为什么要这么做？
Because they take facts personally. People take facts personally. I could talk to you about all that stuff for like nine hours straight. I love it, I loved everything. Oh man, I bet he's looking forward to that. Listen. And I mean straight.
因为他们把事实当成了针对个人的攻击。人们把事实个人化了。我可以和你连续聊九个小时这些东西。我喜欢它，我喜欢这一切。天哪，我敢打赌他很期待那个。听着。我是说真的，连续聊。
No interruptions, no sleep. Ricky, what was that joke that you talked about? You said that sort of that idea of people being offended or online or on social media was the equivalent of running down to the town square. Oh, where people that, yeah, I do it in humanity when this bad woman's arguing with me, getting offended by a tweet. Like I was tweeting them. Like I'm just tweeting, I don't know who's following me. That's like going into a town square and seeing a message that says, guitar lessons. And you go, I don't fucking want guitar lessons.
没有打断，没有睡觉。瑞奇，你提到的那个笑话是什么？你说那种人们在网上或社交媒体上被冒犯的想法，相当于跑到城镇广场上。哦，人们，是的，我在谈论人性时会这么说，当这个坏女人跟我争论，被一条推文冒犯时。就好像我在专门发推特给他们一样。就像我只是在发推特，我不知道谁在关注我。这就像走进一个城镇广场，看到一条写着吉他课的消息。然后你说，我他妈才不要上吉他课。
And say, if people, it wasn't to you. People jumping the way of a bullet and saying, why are you shouting at me? And people have done that on purpose. They've tried to give ideas a human right. That's why, so if you criticize Christianity, people say, why are you criticizing Christians? And I go, I'm not. I'm criticizing the ideal. I'm discussing an idea. It's like me getting offended where someone hates maths. And it's not mine. Maths isn't mine. It's a concept. It's an idea. It's like me getting offended where someone hates maths.
然后说，如果人们，那又不是对你说的。人们挡在子弹前说，你为什么要对我大喊大叫？人们是故意这样做的。他们试图赋予观点以人权。这就是为什么，如果你批评基督教，人们会说，你为什么要批评基督徒？我会说，我没有。我是在批评这种理想。我是在讨论一个观点。这就像我因为有人讨厌数学而感到被冒犯一样。那又不是我的。数学不是我的。它是一个概念。它是一个想法。这就像我因为有人讨厌数学而感到被冒犯一样。
It's not mine, maths isn't mine. It's a concept, it's an idea. So, but anyway, this is for our nine hour podcast. I love that stuff. Oh man, that's gonna be a real hit. I tell you what, part two through 12. When are you coming to Los Angeles? Or when can, Will always gets to see you, always gets to hang out. Two through twelve. When are you coming to Los Angeles?
它不是我的，数学不是我的。它是一个概念，它是一个想法。所以，总之，这是为了我们九小时的播客准备的。我喜欢那些东西。天哪，那会是一个真正的热门。我告诉你，第二部分到第十二部分。你什么时候来洛杉矶？或者什么时候可以，威尔总能见到你，总能和你一起玩。第二部分到第十二部分。你什么时候来洛杉矶？
Will always gets to see you, always gets to hang out. I want to, I won't bring Sean. I see, I do actually see four people when I'm in LA, don't I? I can be small, I have a four and a half. Will and Mitch, we always invite you, but you're always having a body wax or something. Hurry out here, please, or I'll come see you there. Don't make like you don't know me when I call you. You'll never come to England.
威尔总能见到你，总能和你一起玩。我想去，我不会带肖恩。你看，我其实在洛杉矶时确实会见四个人，对吧？我可以很小众，我有四个半。威尔和米奇，我们总是邀请你，但你总是在做身体脱毛之类的。快点过来，求你了，不然我就去那里看你。别装作你打电话给我时不认识我。你永远不会来英国。
I wanna call, what did you call it? Leafy, where do you live? Will's been here. Will calls me up and goes, I'm around the corner. I go, what? He calls me up. He's here all the time, back and forth between Samarit's and.
我想打个电话，你管它叫什么？叶子，你住哪儿？威尔来过这里。威尔打电话给我说，我就在拐角处。我说，什么？他打电话给我。他一直都在这儿，在萨马里茨和这里之间来回跑。
Yeah, he's hopping off yachts and shit. I never go to Samaritza, only Gustav. So listen, I didn't even say it right. No, you didn't. Well listen, yeah, I do miss hanging out and I do miss going over there. I love spending time in the UK and I love spending time with you.
是的，他从游艇上跳下来之类的。我从不去萨马里茨，只去古斯塔夫。所以听着，我甚至没说对。不，你没有。好吧听着，是的，我确实很想念和你一起玩，也确实很想念去那边。我喜欢在英国度过时光，也喜欢和你在一起。
All right, goodbye, we love you. Goodbye, Ricky, we love you. Ricky, thank you so much, man. Guys, and remember, well, you tell the other guys if anyone asks Is he in the SAS? No, he's just a comedian, right? Okay got it Okay Wait play us off real quick with something with that grab that guitar play us off with something just a quick just a quick little Just a single chord. Oh, we didn't have to touch this on here. We go here we go
好了，再见，我们爱你。再见，瑞奇，我们爱你。瑞奇，非常感谢你，伙计。伙计们，记住，嗯，告诉其他人，如果有人问他是在特种空勤团吗？不，他只是个喜剧演员，对吧？好的，明白了。好的，等等，用那个给我们来一段结尾，拿上那把吉他，给我们来点什么，就一个简短的，就一个简短的，就一个单音和弦。哦，我们不需要碰这个。我们走，我们走。
Pretty girl on the hood of a Cadillac, yeah. She's broken down on freeway nine. I take a look and get her engine started. Leave a purring and a roll on by, bye bye. Free love on the free love freeway. The love is free, the free love freeway. Love is free. Freeway's long. I got some hot love on the hot love highway. Going home cause my baby's gone.
凯迪拉克引擎盖上的漂亮女孩，是的。她在九号高速公路上抛锚了。我看了一眼，帮她发动了引擎。让它发出呼噜声，然后滚蛋，再见，再见。自由恋爱高速公路上的自由恋爱。爱是免费的，自由恋爱高速公路。爱是免费的。高速公路很长。我在热恋高速公路上有一些热烈的爱。回家吧，因为我的宝贝走了。
She's gone. Ricky Gervais everybody. Wow. That was awesome. Incredible, Ricky Gervais. Thank you, Ricky. You're beautiful, mate. Ricky, you're gorgeous. Hey, listen, it's getting late You're gonna have to get those those prop awards back to the prop house. Okay, buddy
她走了。瑞奇·热维斯，各位。哇。太棒了。不可思议，瑞奇·热维斯。谢谢你，瑞奇。你真漂亮，伙计。瑞奇，你太棒了。嘿，听着，天色已晚，你得把那些道具奖杯送回道具仓库了。好的，伙计。
Love you, thank you. Bye. Bye. Bye. Oh What a man was How great was that? Well I love that you guys knew him. I've never met him. And I was serious about the influence he had over me, over the show, over... I just... I think he's it. Have you guys ever seen him debate religion with Stephen Colbert? No. I mean I've seen him debate religion with lots of people. He does it online, he does it in person.
爱你，谢谢。再见。再见。再见。哦，那个人真是太棒了。你们认识他真是太好了。我从来没见过他。我是认真的，关于他对我的影响，对节目的影响，对……我只是……我觉得他就是那个人。你们见过他和斯蒂芬·科尔伯特辩论宗教吗？没有。我是说我见过他和很多人辩论宗教。他在网上辩论，也当面辩论。
Yeah, it's really interesting. Wait, does Colbert... Colbert is Catholic, and Ricky's saying... He's an atheist, yeah. Really? Yeah, it's really fascinating. He's incredible. Anyway, I'm a huge fan of his.
是的，这真的很有趣。等等，科尔伯特……科尔伯特是天主教徒，而瑞奇说……他是无神论者，是的。真的吗？是的，这真的很迷人。他太不可思议了。总之，我是他的超级粉丝。
I think he has a brilliant mind. He's an incredible guy. He's so funny, and he's such a sweet... Which is funny because like Jason, you were saying, you know, some of his characters, he can be very confident. Even though he can be self-evasing, he can also be very confident. And he is confident. He's just a smart guy. He's a very level-headed and sweet, sweet guy. And super smart, which is why it was good to have him on our show because he was able to help us. Yeah, I love that thing at the beginning where he's like, wow, are you guys just idiots?
我觉得他有一个聪明的头脑。他是一个不可思议的人。他太有趣了，而且他是一个如此甜美的人……这很有趣，因为就像杰森你说的，你知道，他的一些角色，他可以非常自信。尽管他可以自嘲，但他也可以非常自信。他确实很自信。他只是一个聪明人。他是一个非常冷静且甜美、甜美的人。而且超级聪明，这就是为什么让他上我们的节目很好，因为他能帮助我们。是的，我喜欢他开头说的那段，他说，哇，你们这些家伙只是白痴吗？
Yeah, it's called smartless. Yeah, we go ahead and give you a big hint right at the top. Yeah, I mean, the bar is low and it's advertised. You know, it's like... I want to meet Jane. I want to hang out. Oh, I have met Jane. I've met her, but I want to hang out with her I'm fascinated to see what we'll include you guys. Oh, I'll include you in the dinner. Yes, please
是的，这叫Smartless。是的，我们在开头就给了你们一个大大的暗示。是的，我是说，门槛很低，而且是公开的。你知道，这就像……我想见简。我想和她一起玩。哦，我见过简。我见过她，但我很想和她一起玩。我很着迷于看看我们会包括你们。哦，我会把你们包括在晚餐里。是的，请。
I would love that. Yeah. Smart. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我很乐意。是的。Smart。Less。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。